Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Euh nous sommes sous
ventilateur parce que c'est la canicule
aujourd'hui. Donc on s'excuse d'avance
si il y a un petit bruit de l'arsène
dans les micros à cause des
ventilateurs, mais ça va aller. On vous
reçoit ce soir pour discuter euh avenir
de l'humanité, collapsologie,
développement durable.
bullshit économique, bullshit du green
washing et tout un tas de sujets. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement Laurent ?
Laur Alexandre, je suis économiste et
chirurgien et puis je suis un
anticollapsologue.
Philippe,
c'est court moi. Philippewix, donc je
suis ingénieur, j'ai fait une école
ingénieur généraliste, l'école centrale.
J'ai commis quelques essais sur la
question technologique, la question
d'énergie et de ressources et j'ai
l'inconvénient énorme ce soir, non pas
de représenter la collapsologie, je
pense qu'on pourra essayer de de
reparler de ce terme, mais voilà, de
porter peut-être là une voix plus
environnementale
sans avoir de couette comme Greta et
sans avoir de cheveux longs. Bon,
j'espère que Laurent acceptera quand
même de de débattre avec moi ce soir.
Je t'aurais bien vu handicap terrible.
Je t'aurais bien vu avec des couettes
mais bon. Et moi aussi
on va s'en charger avec Photoshop
t'inquiè
moi ça me va très bien.
De quoi ? Les couettes ?
Les couettes de Greta.
Bon un peu de sérieux euh si je vous
pose la question. Vous voyez la France
dans 5 ans ? Ça ressemble à quoi Laurent
?
Ah, la France dans 5 ans, ça va être une
France fragile avec une recomposition
politique
parce que un parti central, parti
macroniste avec tous les gens
pro-uropéens
et et prolibéraux et puis des extrêmes
autour, c'est pas une situation stable.
Donc c'est un piège. Je suis macroniste,
mais il faudrait une vraie opposition et
là il y a plus d'opposition en dehors
des extrême. Donc je pense que le
post-macronisme va être très très
compliqué et ma conviction c'est
qu'après le deuxème mandat de Macron,
c'est Marion Maréchal ou Marine Le Pen
qui va avoir le pouvoir parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'alternative à droite et il y a
pas d'alternative à gauche.
Pourquoi vous êtes macroniste ?
Je suis macroniste parce que je suis
libéral en économie. Je suis libéral en
mœur, donc je vais pas aller avec sens
commun, je vais pas aller avec la France
insoumis. Donc je suis forcément au
centre là où les gens sont à la fois
libéraux en mur et libéraux en économie.
Philippe,
moi je pense qu'en 5 ans, les choses ne
bougent pas si aussi vite que ça. Enfin,
en tout cas sur disons la la la la la la
composition matérielle ou économique ou
la répartition des des richesses et donc
les tensions qu'on a pu voir ces ces
derniers mois.
euh reste entière sans doute avec donc
des frustrations qui vont se qui vont
continuer à à peut-être parcoup à se à
se libérer. Je pense qu'on va
effectivement voir forcir un certain
nombre de de clivages qui aujourd'hui
euh bah effectivement traverse les
différents partis politiques
historiques. Alors des clivages
effectivement entreah des gens qui sont
à fond pour la technologie et d'autres
qui commencent à douter un peu. des
clivages sur la question sur la question
de l'immigration peut-être aussi euh des
voilà plein plein alors après qui sera
élu président de la République, je vais
pas me lancer dans des dans des
prévisions mais je je pense
qu'effectivement
on va voir continuer à se tendre la
frustration et monter les extrêmes et et
un débat qui sans doute sera pas on aura
pas des conditions d'un débat très
serein comme on l'a pas aujourd'hui.
Laurent, est-ce que la science et la
technologie vont nous sauver ?
Moi, je crois pas à la technologie
salvatrice. Je crois pas que la
technologie soit bonne. Je crois pas non
plus qu'elle soit mauvaise et je crois
pas non plus qu'elle soit neutre. La
technologie est structurante. Parfois,
elle est bonne, parfois elle est
mauvaise, il y a des moments où elle est
bonne. Dans mon univers à moi qui est la
médecine, la techno est plutôt bonne.
Euh 1888, c'est la première apinectomie.
Avant 1888, 100 % des gens qui ont une
appendicite, ils meurent. Quand on a la
paindicide, quand le petit a la
pindicite, le gamin, l'ado, on appelle
le croquement mort et le curé parce que
le gamin va mourir. Euh la rougeol tuait
6 millions de gamins sur terre il y a
quelques décennies. 6 millions avant la
vaccination.
On pourrait multiplier les exemples
hein. Et on connaît les horreurs qui
était la polio, qui était la variole. La
variole a tué des centaines de millions
d'êtres humains dans le passé. Donc dans
mon univers, c'est mieux aujourd'hui
d'être malade que d'être malade jadisme.
En 1950, 100 % des enfants leémiques
mourait et dans des conditions
absolument épouvantables. Aujourd'hui,
la quasi-ttalité des enfants
leucémiques, on les guérit, pas tous,
mais la quasi-ttalité. Donc, c'est vrai
que dans le domaine de la médecine qui
qui est mon qui est mon métier, il
faudrait être ingrat pour penser que
c'était mieux avant parce que c'était
horrible avant. 100 % des diabétiques
mouraient avant l'insuline en en 1922.
on pourrait multiplier les exemples de
de de la difficulté à vivre avant avant
la médecine moderne. C'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que je ne suis pas proche. Je ne
suis pas pour la la tech raisonnable
parce que la cancérologie lot tech
crever. L'infecteiologie l'othèch ça
veut dire crever. La cardiologie l'otèch
ça veut dire crever. Que en médecine il
y a pas de lotch. Soit on crève avec du
lotch soit on est guéri avec de l'ech.
Donc en tant que médecin, j'ai une
déformation, je préfère guérir mes
malades avec de l' high-tech que de les
voir crever avec la lotch de 1850 ou de
1880. Donc la technologie ne règle pas
tous les problèmes mais il y a des
domaines et notamment en médecine où il
faudrait être très ingrat. D'ailleurs,
il faut pas s'y tromper. les adistes de
Notredame euh des Landes qui veulent
qui veulent être lotèch, ne pas ne pas
consommer de et et vivre selon les
précepts de d'Alan DA dans un passé
mythique où il y avait pas trop de
technologie. Quand le petit a la leémie,
on appelle l'hélicoptère et quand on
fait un infarctus, on appelle
l'hélicoptère. Donc même les gens qui se
volent
quand ils sont malades, ils appellent le
SAMU. Ils sont passagers clandestin de
la high-tech. Donc même les gens qui
disent la lotèch c'est formidable, la
lotch c'est formidable quand ils sont à
deux doigts de crever ils font le case.
Euh avant de rebondir sur Philippe euh
pour ou contre l'euthanasie docteur ?
Moi, je suis pour l'euthanasie mais
c'est normal, je suis un libéral donc je
suis pour l'euthanasie quand on le
choisit he pas la l'euthanasie décidé
par l'État. Je suis pour le mariage gay,
je suis pour la GPA, je suis pour la
PMA. Et
il y a il y a quelques jours, il y a un
malade qui a qui a une très grave
maladie dégénérative
et qui est dans un état épouvantable et
qui a réussi à voir mon portable par et
qui m'a appelé, qui m'a demandé ce qu'il
fallait faire. Et il y a rien à faire
pour sa maladie qui est absolument
incurable. et et je discute avec lui des
options et
puis il me dit "Bon, je suis au bout du
rouleau et ça va être la fin va être à
ta affreuse et donc j'ai économisé et je
vais aller en Suisse parce que ma fin de
vie va pas être acceptable." Ça, je
trouve que c'est dégueulasse. C'est dire
que cette interdiction pour les gens de
mettre fin à leur jour quand vraiment
les carottes sont cuites, quand il y a
plus aucun espoir et quand la vie
devient insupportable et n'est plus
digne, je trouve que c'est profondément
rétrograde. Et d'ailleurs, c'est ce que
je regrette beaucoup aux gens qui sont
dans dans qui sont à droite autour de
sens commun, c'est d'être
anti-euthanasie par principe. On l'a vu
dans l'affaire Vincent Lambert sans sans
s'intéresser finalement au au
à la dignité des gens et et au bien-être
des gens. Et pour des raisons
politiques, pour des raisons
religieuses, il s'oppose à ce qui serait
une vraie réforme moderne qui serait une
euthanasie encadrée, hein, une anasésie
régulée avec des collèges de médecins
pour vérifier que les gens sont pas
simplement déprimés mais qu'ils sont
vraiment gravement malades. Donc oui, je
suis pour l'euthanasie. Et je et je
regrette à la droite d'être sur ce point
comme sur le mariage gay, complètement à
l'ouest et complètement rétrograde. Mais
c'est je dis ça parce que je suis un
libéral et que je ne suis pas un homme
de droite.
Philippe, les lot c'était mieux avant.
C'était pas c'était pas mieux avant.
Je pense
parce que la science la science va nous
sauver.
Alors bon déjà le le nous sauver,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? parce que
si c'est nous sauver personnellement,
c'est être capable de nous soigner et de
repousser euh le le moment où il y a
effectivement cette échéance à honorer.
Euh bon, moi je je ne peux que
effectivement reconnaître aussi alors il
y a des problèmes de franchissement
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
barrières éthiques très probablement
mais bon voilà effectivement je suis le
premier à à trouver le dentiste de 2019
très très bien par rapport au dentistes
des années 70, la radio numérique tout
ça formidable. Et donc évidemment, c'est
euh au moindre pépin de de santé, je
serais très content d'habiter en en
France et d'avoir accès à un certain
nombre de de soins pour moi, pour ma
famille. Il y a aucun doute là-dessus.
Ensuite, la question c'est pour moi est
pas tout à fait ça. La question c'est de
se dire d'abord est-ce que euh on on
doit jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain ?
Et donc est-ce qu'on a
Non, bien sûr, c'était pas mieux avant,
mais est-ce que tout va être mieux ?
Est-ce que c'est pour ça que ça tout va
être mieux demain ? C'est ça ça ne
voilà. il y a pas d'automatisme, il y a
pas de théorème mathématique qui dit bah
c'était là on est peut-être mieux
qu'avant mais alors du coup forcément
demain ça sera encore mieux
ou encore moins bien. Donc c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est que il y a un constat d'un état
des lieux de la planète. Alors on peut
être plus ou moins climatosceptique,
j'en sais rien. On peut mais il y a
plein de paramètres sur lesquels bon bah
on est vraiment dans du factuel. On est
la la pollution généralisée au plastique
par exemple. Il pleut du plastique ce
que je mentionnais la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vu, il pleut du plastique au
fin fond des Pyrénées. Il pleut 365
particules de microplastique par mètre
carré et par jour. Voilà, on mange du
microplastique dans les huîtres, dans
dans dans les poissons, dans enfin dans
toutes les chaînes alimentaires
contaminées. Donc il y a quand même
quelques éléments comme ça. Des éléments
sur la question de l'érosion des sols.
Alors on peut tout faire en hors sol
peut-être un jour, j'en sais rien.
Question de de d'effondrement de la
biodiversité en qualité et en quantité.
Tout ça c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment factuelles. Alors après on peut
se dire le changement climatique c'est
pas grave, on s'adaptera, ça montera de
x m à 2100 mais il faut savoir que les
projections du G c'est 2100, c'est pas
2200, 2300, 2500 parce que ça va
continuer à monter, ça va continuer à
fondre et ça va continuer à à se dilater
au niveau des océans. Donc même si on
est là à dire bah ça sera 1 m ou 2 m ou
3 m en 2100, bah ça sera plus en en
2200, 2300, 2400. Donc peut-être qu'on
va tous se réfugier à un moment sur les
pôles et en Sibérie, les Russes sont
très contents du changement climatique
par ailleurs
ou à Bruxelles
hein
ou à Bruxelles dans un premier temps.
Puis après voilà des grandes migrations
comme ça qui rappelleront peut-être en
Eurasie l'inverse de de de des des des
migrations des des horses de barbares
qui envahirent l'Empire romain. Mais
effectivement l'Empire romain on
commence à se rendre compte queil s'est
plutôt effondré à cause de la variole et
quelques autres joyausés de ce type là
que à cause des hors de barbare. Voilà.
Donc alors est-ce que la médecine lotch
? Mais moi non plus, j'en veux pas de la
médecine lotch. Alors je mettrai quand
même quelques quelques peut-être
nuance parce que il y avait un
formidable programme de recherche sur la
détection précoce du cancer du sein par
les chiens.
C'est génial. C'est ultra lot. Donc
c'est en gros on met un coussin, on dort
la nuit avec et après on le fait sentir
à des chiens et quelle que soit la race
de chiens 100 % de réussite pour
détecter le cancer du sein. Bah voilà un
exemple de de peut-être de faudrait
jouer sur la dualité mais du fait qu'on
n'est pas obligé forcément de passer
tout le monde à l'IRM tout le temps pour
trouver un certain nombre de choses. Bon
je ne sais pas ensuite on en passera sur
la c'est difficilement industrialisable.
Alors voilà c'est la question. Moi
j'imaginais un espèce de monde assez
anxiogène avec plein de chiens avec des
des gens avec des casques à poes à
l'entrée de la garde du nord en train de
screener toutes les dames qui passent.
Et d'un point de vue et d'un point de
vue et d'un point de vue juridique, si
le chien se trompe, ça va être compliqué
devant le juge. [rires]
Voilà. Bon après, c'est toujours
son médecin devant le juge, mais bon
voilà. Donc moi je je la question c'est
plutôt donc c'est pas pas de dire qu'on
va le faire au niveau personnel, mais
est-ce qu'on va résoudre un certain
nombre de grands problèmes qui a amené
la technique ? On a un certain nombre de
grands problèmes. On a réussi à
repousser des des des limites de sur les
sur les ressources, sur l'énergie et
cetera. formidable formidable
inventivité humaine mais en même temps
on a fait des dégâts et si on projette
les tendances dans lesquelles on est
aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas
soutenables sur le on va dire long terme
pour être sûr qu'on qu'on tombe à peu
près d'accord encore que c'estd que avec
un taux de croissance de 2 % alors le le
le les les statistiques annuelles de de
BP là qui sortent chaque année à peu
près au mois de juin qui font un peu
référence dans le domaine surtout la
production et la consommation mondiale
des de d'énergie sont sortis là il y a
quelques jours. + 2,8 % l'année dernière
de d'énergie primaire au niveau mondial
et + 2 % en émission de CO2.
C'est-à-dire que les espoirs
de de de de découplage, comme disent les
économistes, de de la croissance en
disant je vais faire de la croissance
économique d'un côté mais je vais
réussir à réduire mes émissions de CO2.
Ça se passait un peu dans les dans la
dernière décennie, on était tombé à même
certaines années dans les 0,8 % 1 % de
de croissance du CO2 contre 2 ou 3 % de
croissance annuelle. Donc on se disait
"Ah, ça y est, le découplage arrive."
Bah non, on patatera. Le découplage
arrive pas du tout. Maintenant, quand on
a remplacé quelques centrales à charbon
par les centrales à gaz chez chez les
Allemands, bah et un peu chez les
Chinois aussi, et bien maintenant c'est
reparti comme en 40 si je puis dire. Et
donc 2 ou 3 % de croissance par an,
c'est juste gigantesque. C'est
gigantesque. C'estàd que par juste sur
l'électricité mondiale, on ajoute la
capacité de production française plus
que la capacité de production française
à chaque année. Cette année, c'est même
deux fois entre 2017 et 2018, on a
ajouté deux fois la la production
dans la phase dans dans la phase où le
tironde cesse d'être miséreux et on sait
qu'il y a une augmentation très rapide
du niveau de vie dans le tier monde, pas
encore en Afrique mais en tout cas en
Asie, on a forcément une augmentation de
de de la richesse produite et on a une
élasticité CO2 qui est pas bonne
effectivement, on n'arrive pas à
découpler alors dans les pays
occidentaux un peu. Bah oui, non euh
pas pas partout et pas à toutes les à
toutes les périodes. En revanche, en
Inde, on ne découple pas et en Afrique,
on va pas découpler. Donc, c'est vrai
que l'explosion démographique qui est à
l'œuvre et la population mondiale
augmente beaucoup plus vite qu'on
l'imaginait pose un problème, non pas
pour la nourriture parce qu'en réalité
le système agricole il tient et il y a
de moins en moins de gens qui sont mal
nutris. Il y a plus de gens obèses
aujourd'hui sur terre que de gens mal
nutris. Le problème, il est
effectivement sur l'empreinte sur
l'empreinte carbone et comme on veut pas
faire du nucléaire, comme le stockage de
des de l'électricité d'origine
renouvelable ne marche toujours pas et
va pas bien marcher pendant sans doute
encore 20 à 30 ans, peut-être pire, on a
un vrai problème. Euh par ailleurs, et
c'est là où il y a une grande grande
ambivalence des écologistes
de de mon point de vue, euh on n'ose pas
parler de favoriser le planning familial
dans les pays dans les pays où la
population explose. L'Afrique sera
passée de 200 millions d'habitants à 4
milliards en pas beaucoup de décennies.
Le sol Nigéria va être à 780 millions
d'années d'habitants. Si on prend les
les données de l'ONU entre 750 et 780,
le Congo entre 300 et 400. La Tanzanie
autour de 250 300 le Niger pourrait être
à 150. Donc on a une explosion
démographique en Afrique sub-saharienne
qui est intenable. Il serait raisonnable
de favoriser le planning familial en
Afrique. Mais quand on entend l'ancien
ministre de l'environnement, Yve Cochet
ou même Aurélien Barreau euh sur ces
sujets là, il propose que tout l'effort
démographique soi fait par les opérains
européens et les occidentaux et qu'on
diminue drastiquement le nombre
d'enfants qu'on a, notamment pour
accepter et pour accueillir dignement
les migrants africains. En revanche, il
refuse
que l'on essaie culturellement de de de
de baisser la démographie folle en
Afrique. Je crois pas je crois pas. Mais
tu devrais prendre tu devrais prendre le
bouquin de barreau et je peux sortir,
j'ai mon kindol là le bouquin de barreau
et ce qu'a dit cochet dans l'OPS du 3
janvier, c'est exactement ce qu'il
disent. Il ne faudrait pas par
colonialisme dit Barreau il ne faudrait
pas par colonialisme qu'on essaie de
changer la culture des Africains en leur
demandant d'avoir moins d'enfants. Donc
là on a une vraie ambiguité. Il va y
avoir des catastrophes écologiques en
Afrique, c'est évident. Alors même que
l'Europe
va améliorer sa diversité. se reboise et
à n'a pas d'explosion du CO2. On a un
problème très important en Asie du Sud
et en Afrique, mais qui est d'abord
démographique. Mais c'est le tabou des
tabous. Chaque fois qu'on parle de la
démographie africaine, on est tout de
suite taxé d'être néocolonialiste. Al
le tabou le tabou il est il est de mon
point de vue en train de il est tombé,
il est en train de tomber et la preuve
que chez bar et pas chez Coch. Alors si
c'estàd queil y a le débat démographique
et le le fait que la conjonction de
l'explosion démographique et de
l'explosion de la consommation par
personne, donc ce qu'on va appeler le
développement, ça a traversé trois
décennies des années 50 aux années 80.
C'est vrai que ça ce ce ça a disparu euh
du débat public qui était pourtant vif
hein, y compris dans les rapports de
l'ONU et cetera dans les années 80 90 et
ça commence à ressurgir maintenant. Je
crois qu'il y a toujours eu cette cette
d'abord les écologistes ont toujours été
un peu mondialistes et je peux dire
enfin voilà ouvert sur sur les autres et
cetera et donc il y a toujours eu cette
question alors dans les années 70 80 c
marqué sur la question de l'aide au
développement et cetera donc
effectivement ça fait un peu dater
maintenant sa c question d'aide au
développement surtout que maintenant
c'est difficile de classer les pays en
développement et les pays développés les
pays émergents sont plus émergents, ils
ont émergé enfin la Malaisie et cetera,
on est sur sur autre chose. Mais ce ce
la question de dire et oui bien sûr, il
faut qu'il y ait une augmentation de
l'éducation des femmes, du planning
familial et cetera dans un certain
nombre de pays qui n'ont pas encore
passé leur transition fait leur
transition démographique. Ça ça existe
et ça se dit simplement deux choses.
Bon, la première c'est qu'on n'est pas
seulement sur l'Afrique hein, je veux
dire, il y a encore des pays Pakistan,
par exemple qui sont qui sont l'Asie du
Sud. Voilà. Euh du Sud et l'Afrique et
on a on a une deuxième chose, c'est que
le coût est déjà parti. C'est-à-dire que
quand bien même euh euh on prendrait
toutes les jeunes filles, les jeunes
femmes et on ferait avec eux des
formidables programmes de de planning
familial et que sais-je, la structure
des de la pyramide des âges aujourd'hui
dans dans un certain nombre de pays fait
que quoi qu'il arrive et même avec une
natalité assez faible. Mais c'est pour
ça qu'il faut c'est pour ça qu'il faut
agir vite parce que parce que 780
millions d'habitants au Nigéria qui est
grand comme le Texas, ça ne peut
qu'engendrer une catastrophe écologique
la pour de bon et même quand on n'est
pas maltusien, ce n'est pas tenable.
Donc là, il y a il y a un véritable
danger en Europe. Moi, je m'excuse
d'être abbageois, mais des problèmes
écologiques, il y en a beaucoup sur
terre. Il y en a en Europe, mais il y a
des
il y a des tas de domaines où l'Europe
s'est améliorée. La pollution de l'air
est moins grave aujourd'hui dans
beaucoup de villes qu'elle était en
1950. He je rappelle que le smog tiré à
la poussière de charbon a tué en 48 he à
Londres en 52 13000 personnes. 13000
personnes en 48 he aujourd'hui l'air est
pur à Londres et il y a plus de smog
parce qu'on a interdit le le chauffage
au charbon. Les lacs des Alpes étaient
des cloacques en 1965.
Le lac d'ACY, c'est une poubelle. C'est
un cloac. C'est un vrai cloac. C'est du
un cloac. Aujourd'hui, le lac d'ACSY est
le lac le plus pur du monde.
On peut boire l'eau sans la filtrer. Il
est tellement pur, l'eau est tellement
pure qu'il y a pas de microdéchets pour
les poissons, ce qui fait qu'il y a très
peu de poissons dans le lac d'Ansy. Euh
la quantité la quantité de forêt s'est
améliorée, certaines biodiversités se
sont améliorées. Je rappelle qu'il n'y
avait plus de loup en France et depuis
92, on a 500 loups qui sont arrivés.
Donc c'est c'est de la vraie
biodiversité d'avoir des gros mammifères
en France. Il y avait pas de lyx
jusqu'en 73 en France. Il y a
aujourd'hui une population de lingue
significative et même la population d'
Non non pas non il y a beaucoup plus des
linges.
Oui bon effectivement mais
non principalement dans le Jura et et
dans les Alpes du Nord donc la
population de gros mammifère c'est
plutôt améliorée. Il n'y a pas que des
catastrophes en Europe. Il y a sur un
certain nombre de plans une amélioration
de de la biodiversité et de les cas de
et de l'écosystème. En revanche en Asie
en Asie en j'ai dit il y a sur certains
plans une amélioration. Je peux pas dire
le contraire. Le lac d'any c'est un de
ses plans. Il n'y a pas que des
catastrophes écologiques en Europe. J'ai
pas dit qu'il y avait que des choses
bien. C'est c'est autre chose. Donc il y
a des domaines dans lequels ça s'est
amélioré. Le bilan le bilan n'est pas
catastrophique
en Europe. En revanche, en Afrique et en
Asie du Sud, là la situation est
extrêmement préoccupante. L'Inde est une
bombe écologique et l'Afrique noire est
une bombe écologique également. Euh
globalement,
l'essentiel du travail aujourd'hui, il
n'est pas en Europe, il est à faire en
Asie du Sud et en Afrique. Ce qui ne
veut pas dire que l'Europe ne ne doiv
rien faire, mais la situation écologique
de l'Europe est moins dramatique que ce
que va devenir l'Asie du Sud et
l'Afrique sub-saharienne dans les 50
années qui viennent. Ouais, il faut faut
qu'on mettre un chrono comme aux échecs,
quoi. Parut. Bon, il y a il y a il y a
plein d'arguments, il y a plein de
choses vraies et il y a plein de choses
extrêmement fallacieuses dans dans ce
que vous exposez. D'abord la question de
dire il y a il y a plein de choses qui
vont mieux. Oui, c'est vrai qu'il y a
des choses qui vont mieux. La pollution
de l'air, c'est un bon exemple. Bien
sûr, il y a eu des progrès qui ont été
faits dans les normes de de ne serait-ce
que des des des voitures, des camions et
cetera. Évidemment, une fois alors le
lac d'X d'Alc, j'en sais rien. Je j'y
vais pas en vacances et je je bois pas
son eau. Mais quand on dit par exemple
la forêt progresse, mais de quelle forêt
parle-t-on ? On parle d'une espèce de
forêt qui regagne sur des d'une forêt de
bosquet qui regagne sur des terres
agricoles qui effectivement plutôt dans
des zones montagneuses ou
semi-montagneuses où bah finalement
voilà les rendements et la productivité
agricole fait que ce sont plus des
terres aujourd'hui qu'on peut qu'on peut
exploiter ni pour les cultures ni
forcément pour le pour les pâturages
parce que effectivement il faut mieux
faire des usines avec quelques centaines
de vaches et des trucs un peu
automatisés et donc du coup la forêt a
regagné c'est vrai mais qu'appelle-t-on
une forêt d'un point de vue statistique
? faut qu'on aille se balader ensemble
dans la forêt des landes. Faut dire il y
a rien. Il y a rien. C'est pas des
forêts. Ce sont des monocultures avec du
pain dou glace avec des choses comme ça.
Et on n'a pas du tout à à à enfin c'est
on peut on peut pas s'amuser à dire que
voilà par exemple le problème de la
déforestation mondiale bah nous ça va
bien et puis en Asie du Sud ça va pas.
Non ça c'est c'est plus compliqué que
ça. Ensuite
ce que je conteste fortement c'est le
fait de dire que finalement le problème
est dans les pays on va dire du sud au
sens large et que chez nous ça va plutôt
mieux. Non, parce qu'en fait nous avons
déporté bien évidemment une partie de
notre euh empreinte écologique dans les
autres pays. Et donc si aujourd'hui il y
a de la déforestation euh euh au Congo
par exemple, et ben c'est euh parce que
on commence à y faire des portations
d'huile de palme. On fait du selective
logging. Çaappelle selective logging.
C'estàd qu'on a on débarque avec des
buldoers et on va chercher un arbre tous
les tous les tous les 2 hectares mais en
fait avec des routes qui qu'on ouvre au
buldozer pour aller chercher cet arbre
là bah pour faire nos terrasses en bois
tropical qui vont être si formidablement
résistantes à la pluie. C'est c'est
quand même ça la réalité. Donc
aujourd'hui, c'est bien en partie en
partie pas que mais le fait qu'un
certain nombre de pays sont devenus sont
devenus sont historiquement depuis
longtemps des fournisseurs de ressources
ou sont devenus usines du monde puisque
quand on prend la la Chine c'est une
partie de ces émissions CO2 sont en fait
des émissions de CO2 qui devraient
quelque part nous être attribué mais qui
sont inattribuables d'un point de vue je
dirais
système économique ou quoi que ce soit.
C'est très compliqué de de de faire ça,
mais il y a des études qui ont été
faites très officielles par le ministère
de l'écologie qui montrent très bien que
les émissions de CO2 en France par
personne par personne donc c'est même
pas juste une histoire de de de
d'augmentation légère de la population
les notre poids moyen écologique
augmente aujourd'hui en France que ça
soit en CO2 ou en ressources à travers
le bilan des imports exports. Grosso
modo, on fabrique des Airbus, donc on
consomme du titane, je sais pas quoi,
d'aluminium, puis on les exporte et puis
par contre, on importe beaucoup de
choses qui sont des produits de de
grande consommation et le bilan de tout
ça fait qu'à la fin, on importe des
ressources et du CO2.
Alors si tu si on prend à l'échelle de
toute l'Europe,
ce n'est pas vrai. L'Europe est
excédentaire à une balance commerciale
excédentaire. Donc l'Europe exporte plus
de produits industriels qu'on a importe.
Donc en réalité nous
en réalité nous nous n'exportons pas
tant de CO2 que ça puisqu'on produit
plus de choses qu'on exporte que de
choses qu'on importe. Donc en réalité
pour la France qui a une balance
commerciale très négative, c'est vrai. À
l'échelle de l'Europe, si on intègre
l'Allemagne et puis l'axe industriel qui
va de Munique jusqu'à jusqu'à Amsterdam,
et bien et bien et bien ça n'est pas
vrai. Moi, j'ai jamais dit que la
situation était parfaite. J'ai dit qu'il
euh ne fallait pas être maltusien parce
que nous ne pouvons pas être maltusien
et que nous ne pouvons pas être
décroissantistes. D'accord. La crise des
gilets jaunes a montré que les bobos du
16e arrondissement et du café de flore
qui pensent qu'une décroissance avec 30
% de baisse du niveau de vie des classes
populaires, ça va amuser les gilets
jaunes, ils se foutent le doigt dans
l'œil jusqu'au coude. Donc les classes
populaires ne volent pas de
décroissance, elles veulent plus de
croissance. Donc d'un point de vue
politique, c'est une impasse si on veut,
sauf si on veut voir arriver les
extrêmes au pouvoir extrêmement
rapidement. Et puis et puis j'ai dit
qu'il faut
quand même voir que la science peut la
technologie peut diminuer notre
consommation de matériaux et d'énergie
par unité de richesse produite. Ça n'est
pas automatique, ça n'est pas toujours
le cas. Mais je vous rappelle que dans
un téléphone portable, il n'y a qu'un
dollar
de métau.
En 2 € c'est moi qui ai fait le calcul.
avec moi j'ai vu sur les tout derniers
alors j'ai vu sur les tout derniers 1
dollar parce que comme tu sais Apple a
essayé de de diminuer son son empreinte
1 dollar donc on voit qu'on peut créer
énormément de valeurs et dans un
téléphone portable il y a une création
de valeur qui est absolument incroyable
d'utilité pour les gens avec finalement
très peu de métaux hein l'iPhone c'est 1
dollar de métal alors que ça remplace
une télé téléphone l'appareil photo, le
camescope et et et plein et plein
d'autres choses. Donc
mais qu'on le change tous les 18 mois.
Donc en fait,
cer, mais comme tu sais, Apple s'engage
à recycler la quasi-ttalité des métaux
des métaux et finalement, il y a très
peu de métau dans un iPhone. Et
l'arrière de l'iPhone, par exemple,
c'est du vert, c'est intégralement du
verre et le verre c'est du silicium.
Avant qu'on manque de sable sur terre,
je serai mort depuis très longtemps.
Donc il faut pas non plus catastrophier.
Le discours catastrophique qu'on voit
émerger à l'heure actuelle, il me paraît
très dangereux. D'abord parce que quand
Aurélien Barreau
quand Aurélien Barreau propose
d'interdire la 5G,
ça veut dire qu'on va devenir un pays
sous-développé et qu'on va être
vassalisé par la Chine et par les
puissances industrielles qui elles ne
sont pas mal déjà vassalisé par les
États-Unis quand même.
Certes, mais c'est pas la peine de
l'être encore plus sur le plan
technologique. Et puis d'autre part,
tout ce discours collapsologique fou, il
va déprimer
il va déprimer et démoraliser les
gamins. Je m'excuse mais récemment mon
copain BAB était à une conférence et il
y a une jeune fille qui a dit euh
"Monsieur, vous ne trouvez pas
scandaleux que mon médecin refuse de me
faire stériliser ? Je veux me faire
stériliser pour diminuer mon emprinte
CO2." Le discours fou,
le discours fou qui n'est pas le tien,
le discours apocalyptique fou rend les
gamins malades. Quand Vargas, la
militante la militante politique fait un
bouquin qui est l'un des cinq bouquins
les plus vendus en France en ce moment
sur la catastrophe et qu'elle explique à
la radio récemment,
je cite, "À 1,5°, il y aura de façon
certaine 4 milliards de morts sur Terre
à cause du réchauffement climatique. Et
si on monte à 2 degrés 6 milliards de
morts, c'est délirant, c'est dégoûtant,
ça démoralise les gamins et c'est
totalement faux. De prendre la question
écologique et d'en faire une question
religieuse et de démoraliser la
population entière, c'est très mal.
Notamment pour les gamins. On embrégade
les gamins en les en les paniquant. Il y
a de plus en plus de témoignages. Le
rédacteur en chef d'un grand journal
français me disait "Ma gamine a été
traumatisée à l'école et on lui a
expliqué sa gamine est en primaire. On
on lui a expliqué que la fin du monde
était proche et la gamine est rentrée
est rentrée
est rentrée en pleurant à la maison. Il
faut arrêter de paniquer les gamins. La
question écologique est sérieuse. Moi,
je ne suis pas un climatosceptique.
Je prends très au sérieux la question du
CO2, des particules fines qui sont très
mauvaises pour la santé. Mais tout ce
discours de folie qui fait croire que la
fin du monde est et la mort de est à
quelques années n'est pas raisonnable.
Quand Cochet dit il y a plus de 50 % de
chance que toute l'humanité meure à
brève échéance, ce n'est pas raisonnable
ce discours apocalyptique, il est
dangereux, il est démoralisant. Puis en
plus, si la Terre doit disparaître dans
quelques années, c'est pas la peine de
se casser le cul pour essayer
d'améliorer le monde qui vient. Il n'est
pas bien de conduire les gamins à tous
cette sous profzac dans 5 ans. Il faut
un discours écologiste raisonnable.
Philippewix, l'effondrement, il est il
est probable ou il est certain ?
En fait, tout dépend de ce qu'on appelle
un effondrement et tout dépend du terme.
C'est-à-dire que à nouveau euh le le
bonheur des exponentiels, c'est-à-dire
faire 2 % de croissance par an, d'être
dans d'être enchassé dans un système
économique qui nécessite la croissance
pour ne pas s'effondrer pour le coup.
Là, je je suis sur l'aspect non pas
environnemental mais vraiment
économique. C'est-à-dire le la capacité
à servir les dettes, qu'on soit un état,
qu'on soit une entreprise, qu'on soit
une une ville, enfin beaucoup de dettes
publiques par exemple en Chine, tout ça
réclame une croissance économique. Donc
est-ce que cette croissance économique,
elle peut continuer advitam et ternam ?
effectivement pendant des milliards
d'années dit par exemple Paul Romer le
le coloréat du prix Nobel d'économie en
2018 he il dit bah l'économie de la
connaissance on s'arrêtera jamais
d'inventer trouver des choses donc on
peut inventer comme ça pendant des
milliards d'années et on va faire de la
croissance pendant des milliards
d'années
qui consomme peu de matière première
qui consommera
la pensée la pensée consomme peu de
matière première
exactement alors après euh on peut
artificielle
consomme consomme des ressources quand
même.
Oui. On viendra après sur sans doute sur
l'intelligence artificielle bien sûr.
Mais donc est-ce qu'on peut maintenir ce
système-là, ce système de fonctionnement
là qui est un système fondamentalement
exponentiel et qui économiquement ne
fonctionne que sur les exponentiels ?
S'il y a pas exponentiel, le système
tombe, où fait le chômage de masse, où
fait les gilets jaunes et cetera. Donc
la la croissance
liée à la destruction créatrice
chumpétérienne avec l'innovation
technologique qui détruit des emplois,
qui en crée d'autres et cetera. Ce
trucl-là est une bicyclette qui ne doit
pas s'arrêter parce qu'il y a pas de
béquille, sinon elle tombe. Or
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des économistes,
il y en a pas un même parmi les plus
hétérodoxes entre eux qui se pose la
enfin qui a essayé de de monter une
théorie un peu différente qui serait
d'avoir ne serait-ce que je sais pas un
un système stable à la John Startm comme
au 19e siècle ou voire même un système
où effectivement on arriverait à faire
une certaine décroissance à minima de la
consommation d'énergie et de ressources.
Donc du coup, on est on est pris dans ce
système exponentiel. Est-ce qu'on peut
faire 2 % de croissance par an advitam
eternam ? Même si on fait un certain
découplage relatif, on dirait qu'on fait
que 1 % de croissance par an sur
l'énergie, sur les ressources, je sais
pas quoi. Il y a pas mal de choses qui
montrent que même une économie
circulaire nécessitera de faire de la
croissance de de de consommation de
ressources parce que ne serait-ce
qu'avec la durée de vie des des des
produits et cetera, le le le temps
pendant lequel les les les ressources
sont capturées dans les bâtiments, dans
les objets et cetera. fait que de toute
manière, même si on recyclé à 100 %, il
faut continuer à extraire et à extraire
de plus en plus ? Et bien la réponse est
non. C'est pas possible à terme puisque
si je fais 1000 ans de croissance à 2 %
alors 1000 ans pourrait dire c'est très
loin. En même temps, c'est quand même
tout proche si on se posait un peu des
questions morales et philosophiques
hein. Francis Bacon c'est c'est 400 ans,
celui qui a théorisé le le bonheur du
genre humain par le progrès
technologique. 1000 ans, ça fait qu'on
aurait multiplié par 400 millions la
consommation d'énergie ou la
consommation de ressources par rapport à
aujourd'hui multiplié par 400 millions.
On peut faire x 10000 paraît-il avec les
énergies renouvelables si on on
capturait 100 % de l'énergie solaire
incidente sur la planète terre. Je suis
pas sûr qu'on qu'on ait envie d'en
arriver là complètement mais bon 400
millions, ça va devenir un peu
compliqué. Donc de toute manière ça veut
dire qu'il y a un moment ou un autre la
physique est étue, les mathématiques
sont étues, on pioche dans des stocks.
Les énergies fossiles, il y en a encore
beaucoup beaucoup trop d'ailleurs
malheureusement pour faire péter la
planète. Enfin, je veux dire pour disons
faire diverger par rapport à un
historique de climat qui n'a jamais été
stable par ailleurs. Mais là, le faire
diverger un peu sérieusement et un peu
rapidement donc on sait pas trop ce que
ça peut donner. Donc il y a plein
d'énergie fossile, il y a plein de
ressources mais il y a un moment on peut
pas continuer à avoir cette courbe
exponentielle. On peut pas on peut pas
voir une consommation exponentielle de
notre consommation de matière première
mais on peut tout à fait avoir des
innovations qui consomment moins
d'énergie de matière première. On va
prendre juste un exemple. La
photographie. H
si on avait dit un jour qu'il y aurait 5
milliards d'appareils photos sur terre
et il y a 5 milliards d'appareils photos
sur terre avec nos téléphones portables,
les écologistes nous auraient dit "Mais
non, c'est pas possible, il y aura
jamais assez de sel d'argent pour faire
les photos. Jamais on aura assez de
matière première sur terre. les les
premiers appareils photo faisaient 30 kg
hein. Jamais on aura assez de matière
première pour que chaque terrien, chaque
africain, chaque asiatique ait un un
appareil photo et efface des milliers de
photos.
En réalité, les appareils photos
d'aujourd'hui,
il y a moins d'un g de matériaux.
C'est essentiellement du verre et là
encore c'est du silicium hein dans nos
téléphones portables. Donc on a en
réalité on consomme des milliers des
milliers de fois moins de matières
premières pour faire des appareils photo
aujourd'hui que jadis. Donc la vision
maltusienne aurait été de dire il n'y a
qu'une petite élite qui aura le droit
d'avoir un appareil photo. Il y a trop
de métal dans un appareil photo, il y
aura pas assez d'argent pour faire les
pellicules. Puis la vision technologique
qui ne marche pas toujours mais qui l'a
marché, c'est de dire ben non, en 2019
tout le monde a un appareil photo, il
pèse quelques grammes, euh il y a
quasiment pas de matière première
dedans. Les matières premières sont
recyclées et donc on a les matières
seclaires sont assez largement recyclées
dans le cas des appareils photos des
téléphones portables. tout à l'heure si
vous voulez mais a des études
parfaitement claires sur le le programme
Nations Unies pour l'environnement c'est
peut-être un repère de cryptoommuniste
maltusien que moins de
c'est pas ce que j'ai dit alors laissy à
moins de 1 %
laisse-moi finir le programme de
recyclage chez Apple il progresse et
dans les années qui viennent il va il va
progresser je suis persuadé qu'on va
arriver à des taux de recyclage qui vont
être raisonnables et de toute façon on
consomme tellement peu de matière
première pour faire un appareil photo
que c'est finalement de de dans nos
photophones on est de plus en plus à en
prendre
que ça n'est que ça n'est que ça n'est
pas finalement dramatique. Donc il y a
des catastrophes qui ne sont pas
arrivées. On en connaît d'autres. Euh,
on sait bien que le Times en 1895
dans un accès de collapsologie
apocalyptique dramatique a a écrit que
Londres avait allait mourir parce qu'il
y aurait en 1920 ou 1930 plusieurs
mètres de crottin de cheval dans les
rues de Londres et que Londres ne
pouvait plus se développer, que
l'activité de Londres allait devoir
s'arrêter,
que les gens allaient devoir quitter
Londres parce que Londres ne serait plus
vivable. Comme comme tout le monde sait,
cette prédiction du Times a été faite 6
mois avant la première automobile. Les
collapsologues de l'époque, il y en
avait déjà, n'avait pas prévu que la
technologie allait euh régler le
problème. De la même façon que euh nos
ancêtres il y a quelques milliers
d'années étaient très inquiets parce
qu'il manquait de silex. Il y avait pas
beaucoup de beaux silex.
Les collapsologues de l'époque, je suis
persuadé, devaient être consterné de la
pénurie de silex. Et comme on sait, ils
ont inventé le fer, le cuivre et ils
sont passés à la métallurgie et on n pas
de pénurie de silex aujourd'hui. On a
régler le problème.
Philippe.
Bon, l'exemple de l'appareil photo, très
bien. J'ai pas de problème avec le fait
que les appareils photo se sont se sont
allégés et consomment beaucoup moins de
matière première aujourd'hui.
C'est possible
dans la dans la Bien sûr, c'est
possible. On trouvera toujours des
exemples. Alors la tarte à la crème la
la plus ultime, c'est le câble de cuivre
hein qui a remplacé qu'on a remplacé par
la fibre optique. C'est super. C'est du
verre aussi, du silicium. Bon alors
façons que il faut mettre quelques
produits pour doper la fibre de verre
dont certaines terres rares comme
l'herbium. Bon pour augmenter les
indices de réfraction mais c'est pas
grave. Et déjà dès les années 30, il y
avait des gens comme Buckminister Fuller
par exemple qui parlaient de
déféméralisation au lieu de
dématérialisation pour effectivement
dire que bah vous inquiétez pas on n'est
pas tombé en on va rendre des services
beaucoup plus grands avec beaucoup moins
de matière. Bon, très bien, ça marche
pour l'appareil photo, mais prenant les
voitures par exemple, il se passe juste
exactement l'inverse. Aujourd'hui, la
voiture moyenne augmente en poids. Donc,
on n'est pas en train de dématérialiser
les voitures, on est au contraire en
train de consommer de plus en plus de
ressources, même si progresse sur la
métallurgie, il y a moins de métal dans
une voiture que jadis. Enfin, elle pèse
plus lourde. Donc une fin euh c'est
qu'il y a plus de métal he globalement
parce que même s'il y a 200 300 kg,
c'est comme les avions, il y a des
hydrates de il y a des fibres de carbone
qui remplacent le métal dans certains
cas et on manque pas de carbone hein.
Ouais, enfin euh
pas trop
ne serait-ce que dans l'atmosphère sauf
que bon pour le pour le produire capter
c'est plus compliqué énergétiquement
ça vient des énergies fossiles. Il
faudrait le biosourcer tout ça ça rentre
dans d'autres questions. Donc il y a il
y a plein de choses qui qui augmentent
et puis il y a toute une matérialité. On
a tendance, me semble-t-il, avec la
révolution numérique à à se focaliser
sur un peu nos objets numériques du
quotidien, le smartphone, le truc et
effectivement toutes les les disruptions
euh économiques et et cette économie
intersticielle qui arrive à venir un peu
perturber la distribution, le marketing,
plein de choses comme ça.
On va pouvoir produire du graphène avec
des arbres maintenant, ce qui va
diminuer le coût par 200 fois. Voilà,
sans doute, mais infiné, il y a a y il y
a plein de choses dans la qui qui sont
extrêmement matérielles et qui
malheureusement vont le rester.
C'est-à-dire que bah une route, je veux
bien qu'on essaie de gagner un petit peu
sur l'épaisseur de de bitum qu'on va y
mettre mais bon ça a des limites quand
on va faire des infrastructures, des
ponts, des lignes grande vitesse, des
aéroports, bah tout ça c'est une
matérialité aussi. Ça consomme
d'ailleurs aussi pas mal de sable et
pour le coup, il paraît qu'il va manquer
plus vite qu'on ne le croit parce qu'il
y a plusieurs types de sables. Il y a
des sables concassés, des sables roulés
et on commence à manquer un peu de sable
roulé qui est du sable de rivière. Bon,
donc
on on n'est pas du tout du tout du tout
en train de dématérialiser. Et quand on
dématérialise
ou quand on fait de l'efficacité,
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement, on arrive
à rendre un service, par exemple, un
service de mobilité avec du covoiturage
euh où on va consommer effectivement
moins de ressources ou d'énergie, bah le
problème c'est qu'on est assez souvent,
pour pas dire en permanence, rattrapé
par l'effet rebond. C'est-à-dire qu'il y
a cet effet volume qui fait que oui,
effectivement, unitairement chaque geste
euh va va représenter moins. Donc
peut-être, je vais dire tiens pour
reprendre l'exemple de des appareils
photos, on va dire chaque euh chaque
photo stockée dans un data center
aujourd'hui va consommer moins d'énergie
et de ressources que la même photo. Mais
on fait plus de photos ou elle pèse plus
lourd parce que on va avoir
une course comme ça un peu de de de
marketing. fait rebond et facilité par
le fait que l'énergie et les matières
premières sont aujourd'hui quasi
gratuites.
Tout à fait.
Il ne faut pas oublier qu'un litre
d'essence malgré 60 % d'impôt coûte
moins cher qu'un litre de badois. Donc
l'énergie est gratuite,
les matières premières sont gratuites
parce qu'elles sont très abondantes et
donc effectivement on en consomme
beaucoup parce qu'il n'y a pas un prix
élevé. Si le cuivre était 10 fois plus
cher, les industriels l'économiseraient.
Si euh les dérivées du pétrole étaient
10 fois plus cher, on les économiserait.
Nous sommes dans une situation de gâchi
parce qu'on est dans une situation
d'abondance des matières premières et de
l'énergie qui ont un prix très faible. H
et si on veut diminuer les gâchis en
tant que libéral, je pense qu'il n'y a
qu'une solution, c'est le prix. C'est de
mettre une taxe sur le CO2, c'est de
mettre une taxe sur l'énergie. Il y en a
déjà mais cela ne suffit pas.
Effectivement,
nous gâchons parce que matière première
et énergie, contrairement à ce que les
gens pensent, sont quasi gratuits dans
notre société et il faut mettre un prix
sur ces éléments quand ils sont
polluants. Alors, sur la pénurie,
j'ai vu récemment un papier qui
expliquait que dans 12 ans, il n'y
aurait plus d'eau sur terre.
D'eau.
D'eau ? Oui. Oui. D'eau. Alors, je je
veux rassurer tout le monde he quand on
consomme de l'eau, quand on boit un
litre d'eau, comme on est en train de le
faire parce qu'il fait très très chaud
dans dans le studio, on à la fin on
pisse un litre d'eau, l'eau ne disparaît
pas. Les seules choses qui disparaissent
quand on les consomme,
c'est le charbon, le gaz, le pétrole
parce que ça se transforme en en CO2.
Mais sinon le cuivre quand on l'utilise
alors malheureusement, il y a un
exception à ça qui est terrible. Juste
le cuivre quand tu l'utilises bah on
peut le recycler alors on peut le faire
plus ou moins bien mais si le prix du
cuivre monte on recyclera plus. Donc il
y a quand même pas mal de domaines dans
lequel il n'y a pas de disparition de la
ressource, il y a juste une
transformation. Et aujourd'hui on ne
recycle pas assez pour une raison très
simple, c'est que comme les matériaux
sont quasi gratuits, on n pas d'intérêt
économique à les recycler. Mais si
demain il y a une vraie pénurie, on
recyclera et on trouvera des méthodes
pour diminuer la consommation de de
métaux. C'est tout à fait le Alors
tu peux être d'accord. Non mais il y a
il y a des choses. Alors l'exception
c'est qu'en fait malheureusement non le
une partie de nos métaux et une partie
alors plus ou moins grande selon chacun
des 60 métaux différents.
Euh les usages sont dissipatifs sont
dispersifs parce qu'effectivement
alors le câble de cuivre c'est parfait.
Je récupère mon câ de cuivre. Mais quand
le cuivre c'est sur la caténère he ce
qui alimente le train, ben le
panthographe qui va user la la caténère
et donc il y a du cuivre qui va se
disperser, ça va être usé, on va pas
pouvoir recycler 100%. Et quand on va
faire de la ving bio, bah c'est pareil,
on va mettre du sulfate de cuivre, de la
bouillie bordelaise sur les terres
agricoles récupér
tu es d'accord avec moi mettre de le
cuivre estant toxique pour la santé, il
faudrait arrêter d'en mettre sur la
vigne
et donc revenir avec des pesticides de
synthèse dont je vais pas dire je suis
d'accord mais c'est un problème. Le
cuivre est plus dangereux et pour ta
santé, je peux te dire en tant que
médecin que le cuivre est dangereux. On
le fait passer pour un produit bio mais
il n'est pas bio et il est vraiment
toxique et il est plus toxique hélas que
les produits phytos sanitaires de de
synthèse. Il est il est il est toxique
pour les et puis pour les paysans qui
l'utilisent. Donc on ferait mieux de
mettre moins de cuivre dans le pinard.
Bon à voir parce que le reste doit être
un peu est pas forcément folichon non
plus. J'en sais rien mais c'est un vrai
sujet et on voit bien qu'en fait quand
on prend les problèmes, elles sont moins
simples peut-être que euh ce que parfois
le débat médiatique amène
à à rendre un peu trop caricatural sans
doute effectivement. Mais donc on a
quand même ces usages dispersifs qui
sont qui peuvent être assez nombreux
hein dans le cas du titane dans le
colorant blanc, dans les crèmes
solaires, bio ou pas bio. Voilà, on a on
a des
le titane dans les dans les dans les
médicaments.
Voilà, on va disperser en fait, on va on
va aller prendre ça dans des endroits
qui ont été concentrés par la planète
pendant quelques millions dizaines de
millions d'années et puis on va aller
disperser ça finalement dans les océans.
On a des techniques pour les récupérer.
D'ailleurs, on [grognement] pourrait
même le filtrer à terme dans les océans
à long terme. Je dis pas dans 10 ou 20
ans mais à long terme on pourrait
récupérer ce qui est dispersé en le
filtrant dans les océans.
Beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie. Non, mais
ça coûte cher, ça coûte cher et ça
suppose qu'on règle euh notre problème
de stockage des énergies renouvelables.
Mais les économistes, donc les
économistes effectivement il y a il y a
cette question du recyclage. Évidemment,
plus la matière première est chère, plus
le recyclage va être moins on va la
gâcher et moins on va la gâcher. Donc
aujourd'hui quand vous recyclez par des
batteries lithium cobalt typiquement
toutes les batteries un peu de de nos
objets numérique du du quotidien et ben
en fait n récupérer que le cobalt cobalt
nickel mais pas la partie lithium parce
qu'en fait c'est ça c'est trop cher
question une question internet une
société minière sur la lune est-ce que
vous y pensez
à
à à très long terme on sait que le
patron d'Amazon pense qu'on va aller
chercher des matières premières sur les
autres planètes moi ça ne me semble pas
impossible mais je ne dis pas que ce
soit faisable ça semble impossible mais
c'est pas demain matin. De toute façon,
il ne serait pas rentable d'aller
chercher des métaux ailleurs sauf
peut-être certains produit de
l'hydrogène mais ça reste à discuter
tout simplement parce qu'il y a plein de
matières premières sur la terre. Si
demain les métaux valent plus cher, on
va trouver des substituts mais surtout
on va creuser davantage. On sait bien
que par rapport aux années 60, le stock
qui existe aujourd'hui est plus
important que ce qu'il y avait en 60
parce que les techniques se sont
améliorées pour récupérer les métaux.
Donc d'aller faire euh 100 millions de
kilomètres en allant sur Mars ou sur une
autre planète, la Lune étant à 300000 km
pour aller chercher des métaux
aujourd'hui n'a pas de sens parce qu'il
reste plein plein plein plein de métaux
sur terre. tellement tellement tellement
plus simple par exemple de faire sauter
le traité sur l'Antarctique et c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'exploiter dans
l'Antarctique des métaux à terme dans
quelques j'en sais rien dizaine d'années
ou
sièclme pas mal de glace c'est pas si
fastoche que ça l'antifque
ça va fondre tranquillement d'aspirer le
fond des océans.
Non mais voilà effectivement d'aller
d'aller dans l'espace c'est envisageable
à long terme. À court terme, il y a pas
d'intérêt parce qu'il reste beaucoup de
métaux sur terre.
Genre les nodules polymétalliques
par exemple,
il y en a plein. Alors, ils sont pas
rentables à exploiter mais aujourd'hui
mais si demain le prix du nickel est
multiplié par 30, les nodules seront
exploités et ils seront il sera très
rentable de de les exploiter. Mais
aujourd'hui, le nickel est extrêmement
peu cher. De toute façon, il y a
quasiment pas de métau cher.
Aujourd'hui, il y en a quasiment pas.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait qu'il
y ait une mine de charbon qui soit
bloquée ce weekend en Allemagne ?
Moi, je suis pour l'arrêt des mines de
charbon. Je suis pour l'interdiction
immédiate des centrales à charbon. La
politique énergétique allemande est
folle. L'Allemagne produit toujours 9
fois plus de CO2 par kilwh que la France
puisqu'elle a développé des énergies
renouvelables en abandonnant le
nucléaire derrière. Donc quand il y a
pas de vent et pas de soleil, il faut
bien faire tourner des centrales à
charbon ou à gaz. Donc le gâchier
allemand est terrible et conduit à ce
que l'Allemagne ne ferme pas rapidement
ses centrales à charbon et et àite. En
plus d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
écologique et et en terme de
consommation de métal, le choix de
l'Allemagne a conduit à doubler la
capacité énergétique allemande. Dire
avant le programme d'éolien et de
solaire en Allemagne, il y avait 100000
MW de puissance installée. Aujourd'hui,
il y en a 200000. Il y a 100000
classiques et puis il y a 100000
d'éoliens et de photovoltaïques. On peut
pas fermer les centrales classiques
puisque quand il y a pas de vent et
qu'on est la nuit, il faut forcément
qu'on ait des centrales classiques. Donc
la politique énergétique renouvelable
allemande conduit à doubler les
installations et dans installation il y
a des métaux, il y a des métaux rares
dans les énergies renouvelables. Donc
c'est complètement débile d'avoir la
stratégie énergétique qu'à l'Allemagne.
Il produisent 10 fois plus de produits
toxiques pour notre santé et de gaz à
effet de serre. Et en plus, il y a un
énorme gâchi visuel parce que avec le
développement de 100000 MW
supplémentaires de capacité, faut plein
de lignes à haute tension et l'Allemagne
est aujourd'hui écologiquement abîmée,
balafé par des lignes à haute tension
qui doivent raccorder les 100000
nouveaux MW de capacité qu'ils ont
installé. Donc je suis pour la fermeture
immédiate de cette et si j'étais
allemand, je serais allé manifester pour
la fermeture de cette mine de charbon.
Philippe ?
Bah oui, effectivement euh
c'est difficile de passer au
renouvelable sans faire de la sobriété
énergétique. C'est ça qu'on est en train
de de découvrir. Le nucléaire, il est il
est euh il est très marginal. Mais
aujourd'hui au niveau mondial, je crois
que c'est 4 % à peu près de la
production électrique mondiale. Il
était pas en Allemagne avant la
fermeture des des centrales
ils étaient déjà un peu plus bas et ils
avaient déjà des centrales à charbon par
ailleurs. Donc euh ensuite effectivement
le il y a il y a beaucoup de débats sur
quel est le bilan global en carbone de
de des des des de de de cette transition
énergétique allemande en carbone et puis
en économie pour le pour le consommateur
allemand. Alors, alors qu'ils auraient
pu faire de de la rénovation euh euh des
maisons, des passoirs thermiques avec le
même argent ou rendre plus sobre les
transports.
En exagérant, on pourrait même dire au
lieu d'installer des panneaux solaires à
Hambourg, et on aurait mieux fait de les
installer en Grèce. Si on avait une
vraie politique européenne, ça aurait
produit pour le même panneau fabriqué
beaucoup plus de kilwh, beaucoup plus de
de de jours par an. Mais ça c'est
difficile à faire effectivement parce
que on n pas
Heureusement il y en a il y a peu de
panneaux solaires en bourg. Ils sont
surtout quand même ils sont surtout dans
le sud, ils sont surtout dans la
Bavière. Quand tu regardes les éoliennes
sont au nord et les panneaux solaires
mais effectivement
plus il y a plus il y a plus de soleil
mais
il y a plus de soleil qu'ambour et c'est
quand même moins bien en ensoleillement
que la Grèce ou carpentrale. Alors, une
question d'internet. Est-ce que le
discours rassurant comme quoi les
solutions existent
pardon, j'ai la ligne qui mte alors
est-ce que le discours rassurant Arrêtez
de faire remonter la ligne, merci.
Est-ce que le discours rassurant comme
quoi des solutions existent pour tout
recycler ne sert pas de prétexte à ne
pas agir politiquement dès maintenant ?
Stockage du CO2,
ils se font plaisir. Stockage du CO2
dans les océans. Filge de l'eau possible
à long terme malgré une urgence avant 20
ans. Est-ce que Est-ce que le fait qu'il
y a des solutions ou le fait qu'on dise
qu'il y a des solutions ça permet
bien sûr le fait qu'on dise que Apple
recycle ? Ce qui est pas le cas, il y a
une très jolie vidéo avec un petit robot
qui démonte un iPhone, mais je peux vous
jurer qu'il y a absolument pas
aujourd'hui de filière organisé par
Apple pour recycler cet iPhone et je
peux vous jurer que les 30 ou 40 métau
que contient un iPhone ou d'ailleurs
tous les autres, moi je ne stigmatise
pas Apple par rapport aux autres he je
veux dire bon
mais de toute façon il y en a peu il y
en a extrêmement mal recyclé parce que
de toute manière effectivement pour
faire tourner y compris d'une manière
économique une filière de recyclage avec
de la métallurgie de pointe
c'est de la pyrométallurgie
[raclement de gorge]
du plomb zing et de du cuivre avec
derrière de l'hydrométallurgie, de la
chimie pour reséparer les trucs et
récupérer les platinoïdes. C'est
extrêmement complex. Il faut
effectivement sur un micropur c'est pas
avoir l'ensemble du truc. Donc
effectivement aujourd'hui ils peuvent
pas maîtriser disons cette cette chaîne
avale et ils ont des difficultés aussi
ou ils auraient des difficultés aussi à
faire l'inverse, c'est-à-dire à prendre
la chaussette par l'autre côté à dire
j'intègre uniquement des matériaux
recyclés issus du recyclage par exemple
dans mes dans mes téléphones pour qu'il
et ça on y arrive pas parce que comme on
est dans une dans un 1000 feuilles en
fait de sous-traitance en cascade où ça
finit dans des dizaines de pays
différents, je dire Fairfon par exemple
qui a essayé de faire un peu ça et de
tracer c'est extrêmement complexe de le
faire. Ils l'ont fait pour trois quatre
métaux qui sont des métaux de conflit.
Mais c'est très dur. Donc par contre si
on élargissait au-delà de la question
des métau mais qu'on prenait des
plastiques ou des choses comme ça, je
pense que le fait de dire ça va être
recyclé ou c'est recyclable est
évidemment une manière de pas trop se
poser de questions en tant que
consommateur. Bah oui, c'est pas grave.
Ah oui, c'est un gobelet en carton.
Merci beaucoup, c'est recyclable et puis
je vais jeter ça dans la bonne poubelle
et tout est réglé. Alors qu'en fait on
aurait pu effectivement peut-être ou pas
faire de la sobrilleté intelligente, de
la frugalité. Alors là, on peut ouvrir
la boîte de Pandor et voir ce que ça
peut vouloir dire d'un point de vue
personnel, familial ou d'un point de vue
plus sociétal et plus système. Mais je
pense qu'effectivement, c'est une
manière de de de balayer le le problème
d'un d'un revers de main. Et je pense
que sur l'histoire du plastique, alors
on commence à avoir des attermoiements
sur le plastique à alors c'est vrai que
ça commence à se voir un peu dans les
océans à force de déverser et puis un
grand journal se posait la question il y
a quelques mois comment faire pour ne
pas avoir plus de plastique que de
poisson dans les océans 2050. Il y a que
deux manières de faire ça, c'est de
pêcher moins et puis de de réduire la
consommation et la production de
plastique à la source. Enfin, le
plastique dans nos pays, le plastique ne
va pas ne va pas à la mer ou céit très
marginalement
on on n'est pas en Asie. Les 10 floves
les plus fourvoyeurs de plastique, ils
sont pas chez nous. Je reviens du
Vietnam, les des riviers le Mong c'est
un océan de plastique dans la scène euh
pour trouver un truc de plastoque.
Alors on trouve des microplastiques
microplastiques primaires sur mesure des
pneus et des micro mais il y a pas de
macroplastique il y a pas de façon
générale dans nos rivières du
macroplastique. Donc il faut pas non
plus penser que la scène c'est le mécong
et va te promener au Vietnam et en Asie.
C'est c'est effectivement effroyable.
C'est effectivement effroyable. Et il
jettent tout. Ils jettent tout
directement dans la rivière. Il n'y a
aucun ramassage d'ordure en en Asie en
dehors de la Chine. Et donc
effectivement, c'est dégueulasse.
Donc là, le seul moyen de traiter le
truc, c'est à la source. Mais attends,
il va il va falloir du temps. Je te
rappelle que à côté de ça, ils ont
d'autres problèmes. Au Vietnam, par
exemple, c'est que ils vont chercher
l'eau de la cuisine
et l'eau qui boivent à côté des
latrines. Donc le plastique n'est pas la
première obsession des politiques. La
première obsession, c'est d'avoir un
réseau d'eau qui fait que on ne lave pas
les assiettes à la sortie des latrines.
Donc là, il y a un problème de de
timing, de développement qui n'est pas
simple. au Vietnam, le niveau de vie
augmente vite et il commence à avoir des
stations d'épuration, mais ça va prendre
du temps. Et donc le problème du
plastique, on va pas le régler, sauf à
bloquer la société de consommation en
Asie qui est le principal pourvoyeur de
de macroplastique. Ça va hélas prendre
du temps. Chez nous, franchement, on
peut faire beaucoup mieux et il y a des
choses, on peut remplacer notamment les
les les cabas en plastique par par du
papier, mais la situation n'est pas
dramatique comme elle peut l'être en
Asie. Franchement,
franchement, il faut dire qu'on leur
envoie un peu tous nos déchets en Inde.
Il brûlent la Go. Non, on leur envoie
pas les plastiques. On le envoie pas les
plas. On leur
Malaie. Malaisie. On leur envoie des
conteners entiers de plastique. Non,
non, pas les plastiques de grande
consommation. Pas à grande pas à grande
échelle. Ce ne sont pas des ce sont pas
des gros vols. J'en profite j'en profite
pour reprendre la parole et vous poser
une question. Un jour, j'étais avec un
un grand signe tank avec quelques
banquiers internationaux. ça devait être
aux alentours de 2008 et on discutait de
l'économie mondiale et et un des
banquiers me dit "Tu sais, les
États-Unis ne cherche qu'une seule
chose, c'est d'évaluer le dollar." Et je
lui réponds innocemment, "Mais tu sais,
ça avoir des ça va avoir des
répercussions extraordinaires
extraordinairement désastreuses sur
l'Afrique." Et le grand banquier
international en face de moi me dit
"Mais tu sais, la démographie nuit à la
qualité des cerveaux."
Laurent Alexandre, est-ce que vous avez
un un est-ce que vous voulez rebondir
sur cette affirmation ?
Quelle est la question ?
La question, est-ce que vous cautionnez
le fait que la démo la la démographie
nuit à la qualité des cerveaux ?
Non, ce qu'on peut dire c'est que quand
le développement écologique n'est pas
bon dans un pays, quand la nutrition
n'est pas bonne, quand il manque des
vitamines essentielles, on a un moins
bon développement cérébral. Il y a pas
besoin d'aller en Afrique. En France, en
1880, il y avait encore ce qu'on appelle
des crétins des Alpes. Comme il y avait
pas de sel, les gamins n'avaient pas
pendant la grossesse de la maman
suffisamment d'iode. Et l'ode est
nécessaire pour former les neurones. Et
donc, il y avait des enfants qui étaient
complètement neux, les crétins des
Alpes. Et on voit, il y a encore plein
de photos de gamins qui étaient crétins
des Alpes jusqu'en 1900 parce queavant
l'arrivée du chemin de fer, et ben il y
avait pas de sel. Et les gamins, la
maman, elle ne elle ne mangeait pas
l'iode qu'il y a dans le sel. Et donc,
il y avait des déficits cognitifs
importants. Les gamins qui avait qui
étaient atteints de de carence en
pendant la grossesse, ils avaient 40 50
60 70 de de cuit. Ils étaient vraiment
très très très
peu à développer sur le plan cognitif.
Donc en Afrique, il y a des il y a des
zones où il y a encore une nutrition
insuffisante et ça a des conséquences
sur le développement des enfants, sur le
plan physique, sur le plan a infectieux
mais aussi sur le plan intellectuel.
Alors, c'est en voie de régression parce
qu'il y a de moins en moins de zones où
il y a des carences majeures
aujourd'hui. Je dis pas qu'il y en a
plus mais il y en a de moins en moins.
D'ailleurs, on le voit [grognement] dans
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie qui
a doublé en peu de temps en Afrique, ce
qui est quand même un bon indicateur de
santé générale. Les grossesses se
passent mieux, euh l'alimentation des
mers est moins carencée qu'elle l'était
dans le passé. Mais pour avoir un bon
développement intellectuel, l'une des
l'une des choses qui est nécessaire,
c'est effectivement d'avoir une une
alimentation euh équilibrée
sans être exposé à à de multiples
toxiques.
D'avoir une grossesse qui se passe bien.
Alors, sur le problème des toxiques, les
toxiques sont pas bons, on est bien
d'accord,
ce qui passe la frontière. Les to les
toxiques sont pas bons. Mais il faut
faire attention sur le lien entre santé
et pollution
et capitalisme.
Entre santé et pollution
et capitalisme,
le l'endroit au monde où l'espérance de
vie est la plus élevée,
le Japon.
Non,
la cinstein
c'est un pays bien plus pollué que le
Japon.
Le Portugal,
c'est Hong Kong. La plus grande
espérance de vie sur terre, c'est Hong
Kong. C'est l'un des endroits les plus
pollués
au monde. Et donc finalement, le lien
entre santé et pollution, il est pas si
net que ça parce qu'on voit qu'il y a
des pays à très forte espérance de vie
où il y a une pollution forte. À
l'inverse, on a des pays avec très peu
de pollution et où il y a une espérance
de vie qui est vraiment dégueulasse.
Un petite pollution au sianur au Congo
ou une comme ça une petite pollution au
mercure.
Me fais pas dire ce que j'ai pas dire.
Je veux juste dire que le lien
le lien pollution espérance de vie,
il est pas si net que ça.
Oui,
il est pas si nette que ça. Et l'exemple
de Hong Kong, le monde parce qu'à Hong
Kong, la pollution est vraiment terrible
et l'espérance de vie, elle est vraiment
très bonne. Donc, on voit que il y a
d'autres facteurs qui expliquent notre
espérance de vie que la pollution. La
pollution n'est pas bonne pour notre
espérance de vie bien évidemment, mais
finalement on peut avoir une assez forte
pollution et vivre très longtemps. Et
puis il y a la question de l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé, l'espérance de
vie tout court,
elle est parfaite à Hong Kong.
L'espérance de vie en bonne santé
parfaite à Hong Kong, c'est d'ailleurs,
tu peux regarder, c'est très
impressionnant. D'abord, ils ont ils ont
un très bon système de santé et ils ont
un très très ils ont un très très bon
suivi des personnes âgées. Nous sommes
bien d'accord, ce n'est pas la pollution
qui fait qu'ils vivent plus longtemps.
Ils vivent plus longtemps grâce à un
très bon système de santé.
et en dépit d'une pollution forte qui
manifestement n'est pas si toxique.
Une question à la volée d'Internet à à
monsieur Laurent Alexandre. Le cuis
c'est iné ou c'est acquis ?
Oh, c'est une question politique euh qui
est qui est difficile.
Les statistiques, les études récentes
montrent que 50 à 80 % de nos capacités
intellectuelles, de notre capacité à
bien lire et cetera sont d'origine
génétique.
80 % ça fait beaucoup quand même.
50 à 80, j'ai dit euh
50 c'est la réponse politicienne et 80
c'est
Non, non, non, non, non, non. Il y a une
vraie incertitude. C'est compliqu c'est
compliqué à évaluer. On sait qu'il y a
une contribution génétique à nos
capacités intellectuelles. Euh on sait
très bien que même si on donne un très
très bon prof de mathématiques à un
chimpanzé, il rentrera pas à
Polytechnique ou à central. Donc il y a
des caractéristiques. Par contre, tu
pourras peut-être aller à Lenard.
Ouais, c'est même pas sûr. C'est même
pas sûr. Donc il y a un lien entre nos
caractéristiques génétiques et et et nos
résultats. Mais le problème, il est pas
là. Comme on peut pas changer notre ADN
aujourd'hui, le problème il est pas
finalement de savoir quelle est la part
génétique. Le problème, c'est
d'améliorer l'école pour permettre à
chacun de donner le maximum par rapport
à son potentiel génétique. Et
finalement, de regarder nos
caractéristiques génétiques est moins
important que d'améliorer l'école. Et
comme vous savez, l'école, elle est
inégalitaire, elle n'est pas très bonne.
On n'y fait pas assez d'intelligence
dans l'école, on ne fait pas assez de
recherche en pédagogie, ce qui serait
nécessaire pour diminuer les inégalités.
intellectuel. Donc franchement, moi le
tabou QI intelligence, il me gonfle et
j'ai souvent écrit queune partie
significative de notre intelligence
cétait d'origine génétique. Mais c'est
pas le problème principal. Le problème
principal c'est d'améliorer l'école pour
que chacun d'entre nous puisse aller le
plus loin possible avec les capacités
inées qu'il a.
Philippe làà sur un truc comme ça, je
vais pas être compétent quiembrasse mal
les trains. Donc c'est casse gueule.
Voilà. Moi, j'aurais tendance à dire
pour avoir expérimenté modestement deux
enfants euh donc chiffre parfaitement
maltusien et et médiant euh bon bah
voilà, il y a des enfants qui ont plus
de capacité, j'en sais rien. En musique
par exemple, prenons cet exemple là, il
y a des enfants qui ont l'oreille
musicale et d'autres peut-être qui l'ont
moins. Et c'est génétique. Oui.
Est-ce que c'est génétique ? Est-ce que
c'est parce que maman a écouté des des
morceaux de musique quand elle était
enceinte ? J'en sais rien. Voilà. Mais
on voit bien
hélas et moi je n'ai pas ce bon gêne là
et je suis nul en musique hélas.
Voilà. Non. Donc le fait de dire donc
juste pour prendre cet exemple là qui
j'espère est pas trop polémique, bon
c'est pour dire que oui forcément il y a
des aspects, il y a il y a des il y a
des capacités alors comment elles ont
été acquise ou pas dans la très tendre
enfance, je n'en sais rien. Et
qu'effectivement vouloir
faire marcher tout le monde à la même
vitesse et atteindre le baccalauréat
et avoir je sais pas quoi, 95 % ou 100 %
de d'enfants diplômés, bah d'une
certaine manière,
sans doute la seule manière de le faire,
c'est de de de niveler un petit peu par
vers le bas. Voilà. Et c'est un peu ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui. Enfin, on le
voit bien avec l'évolution du nombre de
mentions. Bon, il y a il y a quand même
effectivement quelque chose là-dessus.
Alors, une fois qu'on a dit ça, bon ben
effectivement le on a mis beaucoup de
d'énergie et d'espoir dans l'école de
République et qui a été une formidable
machine méritocratique et et à sortir un
certain nombre de d'enfants issus de de
classes populaires ou et cetera et qui
sont devenus patrons de grandes boîtes
du CAC 40, pas que. Bon voilà, mais il y
a des exemples au moins et aujourd'hui
cette machine méritocratique, elle s'est
un peu enriée et effectivement on se
trouve que dans ces grandes écoles un
peu décriées aujourd'hui, bah on trouve
de plus en plus d'enfants de plutôt des
des classes privilégiques. Tu mais tu tu
as tu as tu as un énorme biais. Je vais
te donner un scoop.
Il y a 0 % d'enfants de Maréchau Ferrand
qui rentrent à Polytechnique. Donc les
ouvriers, il y en a tellement moins
qu'aujourd'hui qu'on a l'impression
qu'il y a plus d'enfants d'ouvriers qui
rentrent. Mais c'est parce qu'il y a
plus d'ouvriers. C'estd que avant il y
avait pas de cadre comme tu sais le
cadre n'existait pas. Le cadre est
apparu en France en 1960 donc il y avait
pas de cadre. Il y avait énormément
d'ouvriers d'ouvriers spécialisés. Il y
avait des ouvriers de très très haut vol
dans la France de 1930 qui seraient
aujourd'hui des BTS de haut vol. H
et donc effectivement les la toile et et
ces gens-là étaient d'ailleurs des
membres actifs du parti communiste. Les
ouvriers de la métallurgie aujourd'hui
seraient ingénieurs. Donc on peut pas
comparer le taux de gamins d'ouvriers
qui rentre à Polytechnique sur les
ouvriers de 1930 et sur les ouvriers
d'aujourd'hui où aujourd'hui
effectivement on est ouvrier quand on n
pas pu devenir technicien, quand on n
pas pu faire un BTS et cetera. Donc la
comparaison est très difficile et je te
le répète effectivement c'est si on
poursuit euh l'analogie, on va s'étonner
qu'il n'y ait plus d'enfants de
maréchauffer qui rentrent à
Polytechnique mais c'est parce qu'il y a
plus de maréchauffer ou quasiment plus
sauf pour les loisirs
et c'est bien dommage d'ailleurs, on
perd un savoir-faire. Philippe voulait
tu veux rebondir
? Du coup enfin oui ce que je voulais
juste dire c'est queoup
effectivement j'ai jamais pensé à ça
mais ça [grognement] c'est assez
convaincant en tout cas en première
approche. Bon ensuite donc il y a quand
même voilà il y a une frustration qui
qui existe aujourd'hui. Je trouve que ce
alors le gouvernement actuel est un
petit peu moins techno fasciné que le
précédent mais bon le gouvernement
précédent sous Hollande où on allait
résoudre toutes les inégalités de
l'école en distribuant des tablettes aux
élèves enfin une stupidité absolument
effroyable. Je tiens à préciser, nous
avons des désaccords sur la
colopsologie, mais on a des choses
communes. Je me suis battu battu contre
les fantasmes expliquant qu'on allait
régler les problèmes de l'école de la
République en distribuant des iPads. Et
quand je vois des maires ou des hommes
politiques qui m'expliquent qu'avec des
iPads, il y a plus de problème de dans
les écoles, je rigole. À l'heure du
numérique, il y a 30 % des gamins qui
quittent l'école sans savoir lire et
écrire correctement. Et il y a 30 % des
gamins qui ne savent pas remplir un
formulaire sur internet, un formulaire
simple, un formulaire administratif.
Donc il n'y a aucune amélioration liée
au numérique. Le numérique n'améliore
pas le niveau des enfants. Il y a aucune
étude qui est montrée que ce soit la
méthode magique pour réduire les
inégalités intellectuelles. Donc on a
été techno fasciné et et on a par pensée
magique pensé qu'on allait régler les
problèmes de l'école par les dispositifs
électroniques. Les dispositifs
électroniques ne résolvent aucun des
problèmes de l'école. J'adore la techno
mais je suis obligé de constater que ça
n'est pas différent du placebo. C'estàd
que l'iPad distribué au gamin est aussi
peu efficace que l'homéopathie
distribuée à un malade. [grognement]
C'est pas faux. Question à la volée
d'Internet pour monsieur Laurent
Alexandre. Comment avez-vous travaillé
pour votre carte mondiale des cuits ?
C'est pas ma carte, c'est la carte de
Wikipédia et j'ai dit qu'il fallait pas
la diffuser. Et donc derrière l'extrême
droite l'a diffusé à Toutva et a fait
plein de de de dessins et de montag à
partir de cette carte. C'est pas moi qui
ai fait cette carte, elle est disponible
sur Wikipédia. Hélas euh vous pouvez
aller la consulter IQ on on countries et
c'est pas du tout ma carte. Et j'ai fait
un grand papier dans le monde il y a
quelques mois pour expliquer que les
gens qui essayaient de faire des
analyses génétiques selon les rac, ce
qui était la préconisation dans un un
billet très violent dans le New York
Times du professeur Reich d'arvard et
ben se trompait et que ça n'était pas
politiquement opportun. Donc ce n'est
pas ma carte, je suis contre cette
carte. Je suis contre la diffusion de
cette carte et je pense que diffuser ce
type de carte, c'est le meilleur moyen
d'aller dans nos banlieux à la guerre
civile. Question pour tous les deux.
Vous vous débrouillez pour choisir qui
répondra. Doit-on limiter la croissance
de la population mondiale ? Et si oui,
comment ? Question d'internet.
Bah, doit-on faudrait-il plutôt si on
change de faudrait-il la réponse serait
oui, bien sûr, puisqueen fait assez
mécanique là aussi. A prioriant,
non mais moins on serait Non mais moins
on est nombreux, moins plus l'équation
écologique est facile à régler quelque
part. C'est voilà, si on était un
million sur terre, on aurait tous un
hélicoptère, ça serait génial et puis je
sais pas quoi. Et puis euh voilà, si on
est 10 milliards, c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué. Il faut peut-être
évoluer un peu dans le régime
alimentaire, j'en sais rien. Donc moi,
pour moi, oui, effectivement, plus on
était enfin plus on arrivera à le
limiter, mieux ce sera. Maintenant,
comment ? Bah, c'est la grande question
parce que ça enfonce tous les tabous
parce que il y a des questions
géopolitiques parce que le premier pays
qui s'y mettrait ou qui s'y mettra si
c'est pas la Chine puisqu'ils ont
expérimenté un peu et ben c'est le
risque de se retrouver nanifiés par
rapport aux autres qui eux continueront
à se développer parce qu'il y a des
questions autour de ça. Donc c'est c'est
hyper chargé, hyper compliqué. Mais
effectivement se mettre la tête dans le
sable en se disant il y a pas de
problème, il y a pas de problème parce
que finalement bah il y a jamais eu de
problème. On a toujours eu une une
population croissante et ça ira enfin
depuis le 19e siècle j'entends et et
donc tout ira bien ça me paraît aussi
embêtant. Alors, le problème, il est pas
pour moi, il n'est pas alimentaire. La
terre peut nourrir beaucoup de gens. Euh
mais le problème, il est sur
l'épanouissement, sur la scolarisation,
sur l'évolution du statut des femmes.
C'est difficile de faire évoluer le
statut des femmes et c'est un circle
vicieux quand elle a dit marmau. Donc
pour avoir un meilleur équilibre dans la
société entre les hommes et les femmes,
pour avoir une amélioration du niveau
éducatif, il vaut mieux qu'il y ait des
foyers avec deux ou trois enfants
qu'avec 10. Donc moi, je suis
personnellement favorable à ce qu'on
favorise le planning familial, mais pas
chez nous puisque la démographie
européenne est en train de s'effondrer
hors immigration, mais qu'on le favorise
dans les zones où il y a une explosion
démographique. Et franchement, je répète
le chiffre que j'ai tout à l'heure, que
l'Afrique soit passée de 200 millions
d'habitants à 4 milliards en peu de
temps, ce n'est pas équilibré, ce n'est
pas rationnel. Et en terme de services
publics, en terme d'hygiène, on voit les
conséquences dramatiques. À Kinshasa, au
Congo, pays qui va atteindre 300
millions d'habitants. Le ramassage
d'ordure en 1970, il était présent.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des tas d'ordures
partout avec des risques massifs
d'épidémie. Il y a plus de services
publics, euh il n'y a plus d'état. On le
on voit des phénomènes de même nature au
Nigéria qui qui est en train de devenir
une zone de non droit et d'anarchie. Si
on veut un développement équilibré, il
faut que la démographie en Afrique se
stabilise. Je suis favorable à ce qu'on
fasse des programmes de planning
familial, même si on se fait accuser
d'être néocolonialiste. Et j'assume euh
cet insulte, je pense que pour des
raisons écologiques, pour des raisons
politiques, pour des raisons de
bien-être des populations, il n'est pas
raisonnable que au Niger on continue
dans un coin de désert à faire sep
enfants par femme.
Ce n'est pas équilibré.
Philippe,
bah oui, je suis aussi favorable à des à
des programmes d'aide
intelligents et ciblé comme ils ont pu
exister dans les années 50 aux années 70
où il y avait d'ailleurs les les les
États-Unis qui étaient le principal de à
ma connaissance pourvoyeur de fond de
ces de ces programmes de de l'ONU. Euh,
il y avait pas d'accusation encore
particulière de né de colonialisme à ce
moment-là. On avait pas des on avait pas
encore décolonisé.
Euh si ça ouais 60 70 donc et et les
États-Unis finalement ont retiré leur
fond et se sont retirés du programme
pour des questions religieuses hein
principalement de de pression
de pression de l'église aux États-Unis.
Donc donc moi je je trouve que c'est
quelque chose voilà de de se dire qu'on
flèche intelligemment notre notre aide
au développement si je puis dire c'est
que ça s'appelle encore comme ça au lieu
de dire plutôt que d'ouvrir des routes
et des barrages pour aller chercher de
la boxite et fabriquer l'aluminium des
trucs qui vont nous servir à nous de se
dire qu'on va d'essayer de faire de
l'aide au développement un peu plus
fléché et qui soit plus effectivement à
à soutenir les les populations. Moi je
pense que c'est effectivement quelque
chose qu'on devrait remettre
effectivement sur la table
systématiquement dans les grandes
instances mondiales au nuus et cetera.
Ensuite dire que le moi je pense
qu'effectivement par définition une
famille avec 10 enfants, c'est une
famille qui est quelque part plus pauvre
qu'une famille avec trois enfants. C'est
sû y
compris sur le plan culturel.
Alors sur le plan culturel, j'en sais
rien mais c'est sans doute alors c'est
les grands qui doivent s'occuper.
C'est plus facile de faire les devoirs à
trois enfants qu'à 10 le soir.
Voilà. à 10, c'est des grands qui
s'occupent des petits, j'en sais rien.
Bon, il y a une autre manière de faire
sans doute. On a eu un moment aussi des
familles à 10 enfants et puis peut-être
certains ont fait polytechnique, je ne
sais pas. Mais par contre, c'est sûr
qu'on est plus pauvre. Par définition,
on est plus pauvre. Alors, si on est
paysan du Niger et qu'on doit faire
hériter de sa terre, ben si on la sépare
en cet enfant et qu'en plus le sol
s'érode et se désertifie, c'est quand
même compliqué pour tout le monde. Mais
à la limite, je pense que si on on
faisait fille de quelques allocations
familiales aujourd'hui, même en France,
si on a quatre enfants, bah on parle
moins loin en vacances ou je sais pas
quoi parce que bah il faut mener les
quatre enfants en vacances, il faut les
loger, il faut faire plein de choses
donc et s'il faut leur payer des cours
de musique et et de théâtre en plus, ça
c'est encore plus compliqué. Donc
effectivement euh voilà, moi je je pense
que il faut il faut essayer de
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat et
complexe et de longue haleine sur lequel
il faut jamais renoncer et avancer.
Effectivement
assez souvent dans la population écolo,
on balaye le truc d'un ver de main sur
le mode bah non, on peut nourrir tout le
monde, ça dépend juste du régime
alimentaire, ce qui est vrai. Mais
effectivement, il y a pas il y a pas que
la question de se nourrir. Il faut il
faut habiter, il faut se déplacer, il
faut s'éclairer.
Bon,
il faut des écoles,
voilà, il faut des services, il faut de
la consommation et donc c'est tout ça
qui ne qui fait que ça tient pas. C'est
pas juste la question alimentaire.
Question d'internet pour monsieur
Laurent Alexandre. Pourrait-il
développer son point de vue sur les
futures inégalités [rires] créées ou
résolues par l'intelligence artificielle
?
Oh bah, j'ai beaucoup écrit là-dessus.
C'est sûr que quand les robots sont
progressivement dotés d'intelligence
artificielle, même s'il n'y a pas de
conscience artificielle, ben il y a des
métiers qui disparaissent, hein. Dans le
point, Benjio, l'un des trois plus
grands spécialistes mondiaux du deep
learning euh expliquait il y a quelques
mois, euh ce serait politiquement
correct de dire que les chauffeurs
routiers qui vont être remplacés par des
camions autonomes vont devenir data
scientistes.
Mais mais ce n'est pas réaliste.
Oui, les chauffeurs routiers si on rend
si on met en place des camions
autonomes, leur reconversion ne va pas
être si simple que ça. Donc la
reconversion des métiers intellectuels
va pas poser beaucoup de problèmes. En
revanche, la reconversion des gens qui
ont des métiers manuels et qui n'ont pas
une formation très développée, elle va
être problématique. Euh des exemples,
comment
des exemples ? Caissière, couturière.
Alors, les métiers créatifs ne seront
pas concernés puisque il est peu
probable qu'on ait des intelligences
artificielles créatives dans les deux
trois prochaines décennies. Mais les
métiers manuels, si demain on a des
robots Boston Dynamics qui font le
ménage dans les dans les dans les dans
les chambres d'hôtel et qui bossent euh
24h/ 24, euh c'est vrai que euh les
ouvrières syndiqués vont risquer d'être
en compétition euh difficile avec les
automates du futur. On pourrait
multiplier les exemples. Donc
effectivement, les emplois relativement
peu qualifiés qui vont être remplacés
par des automates de TDIA dans les de 3
4 5 décennies qui viennent vont poser un
problème de réorganisation du travail
bien sûr et puis de formation continue
des gens. Et le système de formation
continue dans un pays comme la France
qui est un fromage que se partage les
syndicats de patron et puis les
syndicats ouvriers n'est pas du tout
adapté. Il est parfaitement adapté à
faire du copinage, mais il est pas du
tout adapté à faire de la formation
continue des gens pour les rendre
compétitifs face à l'intelligence
artificielle de 2020, de 2030, de 2040.
Donc il y a un moment où il fall va
falloir arrêter le scandale de la
formation continue en France parce que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent qui est
gâché dans la formation continue en
France et en faire un vrai outil de
reconversion des gens et de dynamisation
des gens pour qu'ils soient compétitifs
face à l'IA. Ça va pas se faire demain
matin. Lia va pas remplacer les métiers
demain matin. Mais d'ici 2050, ça va
être un vrai vrai vrai sujet. Et il faut
pas oublier que les gamins qui rentrent
à l'école aujourd'hui seront encore sur
le marché du travail en 2070.
Euh Philippe, l'intelligence
artificielle, énergie vor, pas énergie
vor, est-ce que ça va ça va nous aider ?
Est-ce que le deep learning va nous
aider à résoudre le problème climatique,
démographique, énergétique ? Est-ce que
c'est une chimère ? Est-ce que c'est
quoi ?
Alors, je je pense que
personne n'est capable aujourd'hui de
savoir dans le 1000 feuilles numérique
quel est l'impact euh de la partie euh
intelligence artificielle par rapport
euh aux vidéos de streaming, euh au aux
échanges de de mail ou que sais-je,
sur lequel il y a quand même de lien
aussi. Oui, par ailleurs. Mais cette
espèce de couche un petit peu de Alors,
il y a quelques exemples. Il y a des Je
crois que Google par exemple avait
communiquer sur la puissance
le le nombre total de de de processeurs
qu'ils avaient mis en ligne, enfin en
parallèle plutôt pour Alpha Go. Donc on
peut retrouver des voilà une
consommation disons énergétique précise
sur un sur un action précise qui était
effectivement de de battre le champion
du monde de GO. Bon mais sinon c'est un
peu compliqué. Ce qu'on peut savoir, ce
qu'on sait, c'est que il y a
le le numérique est aujourd'hui
extrêmement consommateur. L'ensemble de
la de la de la chaîne numérique
fabrication, utilisation,
ressources et cetera consomme de l'ordre
de de 10 à 15 % de l'électricité
mondiale. De l'électricité mondiale,
donc ça fait peut-être diviser par de
pour faire l'énergie mondiale, on va
dire pour faire simple. Ça ça croit
alors une partie de cette énergie, c'est
là que c'est assez terrible, sert à
chauffer les appartements l'hiver à la
limite et les maisons hein parce que
c'est de la chaleur fatale. Donc le
l'ordinateur que vous avez à la maison,
si vous laissez allumer en hiver et que
votre chauffage est régulé, je précise,
c'est moins grave que quand vous allumez
vos ordinateurs par un jour comme
aujourd'hui ou là au contraire, en plus,
il va falloir climatiser le TGV dans
lequel vous regardez votre ordinateur.
Mais bon, globalement, on a une facture
qui est qui est non négligeable. Le
problème de cette facture, c'est qu'elle
augmente de manière un peu
exponentielle, c'estàd qu'il y a un
progrès technologique phénoménal.
phénoménal
sur le gain unitaire de consommation de
l'ensemble de ces équipements-là
et que il y a un effet rebond encore
plus phénoménal et donc aujourd'hui il y
a une croissance de ce secteur de la du
coût énergétique de ce secteur qui est
supérieur au au trafic aérien par
exemple c'est plus d'un milliard de
tonnes de CO2 pour 600 700 millions je
crois de de transport aérien. Donc ça
c'est c'est un vrai sujet.
C'est un vrai sujet. Alors, il y a
quelques
fantasmes à mon avis un peu trop grand
euh sur euh sur comment ça peut se
développer parce qu'effectivement du
coup quand on projet de ça, alors on dit
bah 50 % de la facture énergétique
mondiale en 2030 ou 40, c'est numérique.
J'ai j'ai un peu du mal à y croire mais
bon, après tout, rendez-vous en 2030 ou
40. Euh il y a quelques fantasmes pour
le coup. On sait que ça fonctionnera pas
comme ça par exemple sur la sur le
Bitcoin, la blockchain. Donc le Bitcoin
euh c'est vraiment un truc affreux d'un
point de vue énergie enfin énergie parce
que on est sur la base d'une preuve de
travail donc il faut faire tourner
vraiment les ordinateurs, des
processeurs. Donc il faut consommer de
l'énergie quasiment pour faire cette
preuve de travail. Toutes les
technologies blockchain fonctionnent pas
sur ce principe là. Donc je sais pas,
c'est pas Libra par exemple qui va qui
va faire forcément exploser la la
facture énergétique mondiale. Bon, une
fois qu'on a dit ça, la la question
c'est de dire j'ai fait tous les progrès
que je pouvais sur la partie
consommation des équipements parce que
moins je consomme, moins c'est cher,
plus mon service est économique donc
tout le monde a intérêt à le faire mais
ça se ça augmente quand même. Et donc on
se réfugie, le secteur numérique se
réfugie en disant "Mais oui mais moi je
vais faire économiser la facture aux
autres. Je vais faire du covoiturage,
donc dans les transports, je vais être
meilleur. Je vais faire des smart city,
des smart grilles, des je sais pas quoi.
Donc je vais être meilleur dans la
consommation des villes et cetera. Et
là, malheureusement et ben on tombe sur
cette question de effet rebond ou pas
effet rebond. effet système c'estàd que
aujourd'hui finalement
voilà on fonctionne comme au 19e siècle
quand Edison a inventé l'électricité
enfin plutôt la la production
d'électricité industrialiser la
production d'électricité ben au lieu
d'avoir une lampe à pétrole qui
salissait tout à la maison j'avais une
ampoule électrique très propre mais à
l'autre bout de la ville j'avais la
centrale à charbon ou l'usine à gaz qui
produisait l'électricité et qui elle
était très très sale et était évidemment
au charbon à l'époque avant que la
houille blanche et l'hydroélectrique
prennent
en partie euh la production et et donc
on est là, c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire que finalement
on a l'impression d'être propre et puis
on va déporter un peu les choses
ailleurs sous forme de d'externalité
environnementale ou sous forme de
travail d'ailleurs parce que le camion
autonome qui résout un vrai problème
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui parce qu' un
problème de main d'œuvre
on trouve plus aujourd'hui ça y est on a
été jusqu'au Bulgar et au aux Ukrainiens
après avoir fait les Polonais, les
Portugais, les Espagnols et donc plus
personne aujourd' veut conduire des
camions en tout cas au prix
pour le salaire de
pour le salaire où donc on peut aussi
remonter le salaire, c'est une autre
manière de faire mais moi j'ai donc
c'est c'est quoi c'est du le travail il
est toujours là parce qu'en fait
finalement on aura remplacé un travail
salarié pas forcément formidable j'en
sais rien par du travail qui aurait été
fait ailleurs par les petites mains de
Foxconc ou je sais pas trop qui à
l'autre bout de la planète donc mais
mais voilà il y a il y a il y a un
moment où le le voilà le le truc risque
de pas reboucler parce que à chaque fois
on revient sur la question de est-ce que
je regarde par le petit bout de la
langette sur un impact local où j'arrive
à résoudre un sujet ou pas et puis un
impact plus global et plus planétaire où
finalement il y a une division
internationale du travail hein, c'était
des gros mots, on parlait de ça
autrefois, c'est toujours un peu la même
chose. Donc on a des prospectivistes
comme Rifkin par exemple qui il y a plus
de 15 ans ou 20 ans, je sais plus avait
prédit la fin du travail. Bon la fin du
travail, elle est pas là parce que c'est
vrai que le robot de Boston Dynamics qui
nettoie les toilettes, j'ai beaucoup de
mal à croire qu'il soit rentable
économiquement. Il coûte un million et
demi de dollars pièces donc il est pas
rentable aujourd'hui.
Donc voilà. Alors à part peut-être la
femme de ménage de Dominique Froscan au
Sophitel, personne n'est à ce bosc des
qui ne font pas la félation.
Ouais mais je voulais pas pardon pardon
pardon je voulais pas rentrer dans les
domaines un peu comment vous savez
donc mais par exemple dans le bâtiment
qui a un endroit où il y a des vrais
problèmes de de de main d'œuvre et
cetera, c'est un métier qui est
extrêmement difficile à à numériser, à
automatiser, à robotiser parce qu'en
fait il faut s'adapter un petit peu à
des trucs. On a essayé d'industrialiser
le bâtiment, ça a jamais vraiment
marché. Bon, faut toujours s'adapter à
des trucs un petit peu voilà, la porte
tombe pas tout à fait comme on pensait,
faut reprendre un peu un truc et tout et
ça le robot il va avoir vraiment
beaucoup de mal à faire ça avant.
J'ai parlé dans plusieurs décennies
hein. Oui.
J'ai dit c'est pas demain matin.
Voilà. Mais euh
non mais tu as Non mais tu as raison.
C'est qu'effectivement la baisse de la
consommation d'énergie par unité de
puissance informatique, elle est
spectaculaire. On peut pour faire une
opération par seconde, le coût a sans
doute divisé par divisé par 1 million de
milliards. Le coût énergétique.
1 million de milliards. 1 million de
milliards. Oui. Oui. Tu sais un iPhone
c'est 5000 milliards d'opérations par
seconde. La puissance informatique son
coût s'est effondré mais notre
consommation de puissance informatique a
augmenté beaucoup plus vite que le coût
s'effondrait. Donc effectivement, on se
retrouve avec une facture qui représente
plusieurs pour de la consommation
électrique mondiale. Alors, est-ce que
c'est anormal que le cœur de la
civilisation qui est le numérique
consomme beaucoup d'électricité ? Moi,
je ne le pense pas. Je ne serais pas
choqué si en 2050 les diagnostics
médicaux sont faits par des IA, si de
plus en plus si les voitures autonomes
sont conduites par des IA. Je ne serais
pas choqué qu'en 2050 et bien euh l'IA,
les le big data et les et et les cloud
centers représentent 30 40 50 % de la
consommation mondiale d'électricité si
cela crée 30 40 ou 50 % de la euh
production économique mondiale.
Est-ce que vous accepteriez de vous
faire gouverner par une intelligence
artificielle ? Mais
le problème ne se pas. L'intelligence
artificielle n'a pas de conscience
artificielle. elle est incapable de
prendre des décisions politiques
complexes et transversales. Donc la
question ne pourrait se poser que si on
avait une intelligence artificielle
forte, mais on en est très très loin. Et
quand Martin Ford a colligé la vie des
23 meilleurs spécialistes mondiaux de
l'IA sur quand est-ce qu'une
d'intelligence artificielle pourrait
avoir une conscience artificielle et
donc être ce qu'on appelle une
intelligence artificielle forte, les
réponses se sont étagées entre 2029, les
gens de Google
et 2199
pour des gens plus réalistes ou plus
pessimistes. Donc on a un écart énorme.
Personne aujourd'hui personne
aujourd'hui n'a le même avis que son
voisin sur la possibilité d'avoir une
intelligence artificielle dotée de
conscience artificielle rapidement.
Alors parlons un peu transhumanisme,
parlons un peu aussi modification
génétique.
Le transhumanisme ça va nous aider, ça
va pas nous aider Philippi Wix ?
Alors si c'est un transhumanisme sur le
mode les cheveux,
hein. Alors bon oui l'immortalité des
cheveux gris, c'était qui était déjà
d'ailleurs prévu au 17e siècle par
certains penseurs et philosophes
anglais.
Le mieux c'est d'avoir le variant
génétique qui protège de la calvicie.
Voilà. Alors du coup euh
que que moi j'ai
ou Jérôme Camusac.
Voilà. Mais même malgré ça, il y a le
stress du cheveux gris, hein. Donc sans
même passer à la calviciie, il y a le
stress du cheveux gris. Bon, est-ce
qu'on peut faire l'immortalité du cheveu
avant de faire l'immortalité de du du
corps ou de l'esprit ?
le
moi je pense que c'est pareil dans dans
le franumisme, il y a tellement de de
choses, c'est un mot un mot tellement
valise. Alors si c'est la question de
dire je modifie l'être humain dans sa
dans sa conception
par eugénisme ou autre d'ailleurs hein,
éventuellement il peut y avoir cette
frange là par exle on réduit tous de
taille. Il y a des papiers scientifiques
comme ça en disant on devient tous de
plus en plus petit. Alors on est aussi
nombreux mais pourrait tomber à zéro. Il
y a il y a eu un film il y a des
collapsologues transhumanistes qui
veulent qu'on devienne plus petit pour
moins moins bouffer
avec Mat Damon, il y a eu un film où ils
sont tout petits,
ils ont des diamants énormes.
Franchement pas très rigolo. [rires]
Et puis bon, je pense qu'en plus il y a
il y a a il y a des problèmes, c'est
qu'en fait la matière à tout n'est pas
homothétique dans le dans les échelles.
C'est par exemple, vous savez qu'un un
insecte peut assez facilement se noyer
dans une dans une dans une simple bulle
d'eau parce qu'en fait il y a la tension
superficielle de l'eau qui fait qu'en
fait il arrive pas à s'en dépatouiller.
dire qu'on ferait tous 10 cm de haut et
que ça se passerait exactement pareil et
quand on ouvre le robinet, ça serait la
même eau qui coule avec la même courbe
de l'eau de tension superficielle dans
le verre, ça marcherait pas du tout
comme ça. Donc je pense qu'effectivement
ça va rester du domaine de la
science-fiction. Alors si ensuite
transhumanisme c'est de dire je repousse
l'âge de la mort parce que j'arrive à à
avec un certain nombre de dispositifs
complémentaires.
Bon bah là c'est un peu un sujet parce
que qui dit taux de mortalité et taux de
taux de natalité dit d'augmentation ou
pas de la population. Donc on en revient
tout à l'heure et donc on est
systématiquement d'ailleurs le test
était sympathique aujourd'hui c'est de
se dire dès qu'on parle de démographie
on ne parle que de natalité alors que un
bon tiers pour pas dire plus aujourd'hui
par de l'augmentation de la population
française ça a été l'allongement de la
durée de viequ et voilà et c'est vrai
partout donc moi je me dis on a un
problème écologique on est en train de
dire qu'on est trop nombreux et puis on
voudrait tous vivre quand même plus
longtemps. Bon alors évidemment c'est
toujours mieux quand c'est le voisin qui
meurt en premier c'est sûr. Bon donc ça
c'est un autre sujet. Alors après, il y
a des transhumanistes+ c'est la version
bah non, on se télécharge tous le
cerveau dans un ordinateur. Donc d'une
part, ça permet de faire la conquête
galactique parce que sans sans être
passer en numérique, ça va être quand
même très dur de faire la conquête
galactique de Jeff Bezos avec les 1000
milliards de l'êtes humains qui vontir
la galaxie parce que bon bah les les
trajets
disons d'une étoile à l'autre sont quand
même un petit peu un petit peu long et
pénible et il y a des sujets de
radiation et haute qui fait que ça va ça
sera compliqué si on n'est pas sur un
support numérique. Donc il y a ce
transismanisme là. Celui-là,
franchement, moi je le trouve aussi
prospectif et et
Oui. Et puis bon, c'est on est sur un
on est sur un sujet qui est qui est euh
enfin aussi prospectif que la
conscience. Voilà, c'est c'est enfin la
conscience planétaire dont on parlait
tout à l'heure en 2199 ou en 2029. Moi,
j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire qu'on va
réussir un jour à télécharger un cerveau
sur ordinateur et puis qu'est-ce que ça
voudra dire ? Alors, on pourra répliquer
son cerveau. Il y aura plusieurs mois.
Quel sera le mois de base ? J'en verrai
un mois chez mes beaux-parents pendant
que je resterai à jouer à PlayStation.
Enfin bon, ça paraît un petit peu enfin
c'est pour moi c'est un peu trop
prospectif.
Moi j'en pas chez mes beaux-parents
parce que je m'entends pas très bien
avec ma belle-mère.
Voilà, c'est pour ça envoie donc on
envoie une seule version qui est la
version un peu backup pénible et puis on
reste à la maison tranquillement. Voilà.
Et puis un un dernier transhumanisme et
peut-être plus un transhumanisme de
l'homme augmenté au sens je rajoute des
dispositifs
des puces, des interfaces machine, des
trucs qui fait que bah j'ai le bras de
Boston Dynamics pour jouer au tennis,
j'ai euh la puce qui va bien pour parler
tous les langages du monde en en
traduction automatique et cetera. Et là,
d'une part alors sur certains trucs, on
n'est pas dans du prospectif, sur
d'autres on est dans du ultra
prospectif. Et là, tout a été écrit en
science-fiction. Enfin, on peut aller
chercher des quelques bouquins des
années 50 aux années aux années 2000 et
voilà, ça me paraît être une humanité
assez étrange, mais effectivement euh il
y a ce risque de dire si c'est dispo, il
y a un théorème comme ça, je me souviens
plus de qui, je crois que c'est un
hongrois qui dit si quelque chose peut
être inventé, alors ça sera inventé et
il y aura un marché pour ça.
J'ai une question pour Laurent
Alexandre. la technologie Crispe,
l'édition l'édition génétique des
vivants pour compte ça va nous apporter
des choses bien est-ce que c'est
toujours placé pour traiter des maladies
et par exemple pour traiter la myopathie
pour traiter les rétinopathies qui
rendent des gamins aveugles. Ça va être
formidable mais on voit bien que la
première utilisation qui a été faite et
médiatisée enfin l'une des plus
importantes c'est de fabriquer des bébés
en éprouvettes en Chine 3
et de modifier de modifier leur ADN sur
un gène qui est impliqué dans le
fonctionnement cérébral. Donc ça pose
des vraies questions. On voit que entre
la réparation et l'augmentation
transhumaniste, les deux ont démarré à
peu près au même moment. Alors que les
gens imaginaient bien que crisp, on le
réserverait à traiter les petits enfants
malades et qu'on on ferait pas de
l'augmentation. Mais en réalité, la
pression en Asie pour faire de
l'augmentation, elle est forte même si
le le chercheur va probablement être
quand même sanctionné. Mais en tout cas,
son université l'a laissé bosser. il a
pas été dénoncé par son équipe alors
qu'aux États-Unis, on aurait appelé la
police fédérale immédiatement. Donc
Crispe, c'est formidable mais Crisp va
permettre de faire de le génisme positif
et de modifier l'ADN. C'est pas la façon
la plus simple. La sélection
embryonnaire sans utiliser Crispe est
plus simple que d'utiliser Crisp CAS.
Euh l'encadrement va être très
difficile. Il faudrait une législation
internationale, sinon on aura du
tourisme. On aura du tourisme
international. On sait bien ce qui s'est
passé quand la l'IVG n'était pas
autorisé en France. Les ouvrières
avortaient au persil puis à l'aiguille à
tricoter et puis les bourgeoises du 16e
prenaient l'avion et allaient dans des
cliniques chic à Londres. Donc on
risquerait d'avoir la même chose. C'estd
que il y aurait interdiction de
l'augmentation pour les pauvres. Euh et
puis les riches, ils prendraient l'avion
pour aller faire fabriquer leur bébé à
Singapour. on risquerait d'avoir des
inégalités de de de même nature. Moi,
mon sentiment, c'est qu'on autorisera
l'augmentation pour tout le monde et
qu'à long terme, la sécurité sociale
favorisera le génisme intellectuel de
manière à diminuer les inégalités
intellectuelles et éviter qu'il y ait
des processus révolutionnaires avec trop
de gens qui ne sont pas adaptés à à la
lutte face aux intelligences
artificielles du futur. Donc je pense
que le génisme positif à moyen terme, il
sera finalement une nouvelle facette de
l'État providence et que constatant
l'échec de l'école pour réduire les
inégalités intellectuelles, on utilisera
une technique neurogénétique, des
technologies biologiques parce qu'on
considérera demain que les inégalités
intellectuelles accept actuelles que
l'on accepte, elles sont intolérables et
que finalement si on fait le parallèle
avec la médecine en 1750,
les riches
voyait un gamin pauvre, un gamin
d'ouvrier crever sans soin et il levait
pas le petit doigt, on considérait que
c'était normal. Aujourd'hui, c'est
inacceptable. Personne n'accepterait
qu'un enfant pauvre n'est pas la
meilleure chimiothérapie contre la
leucémie. En revanche,
chez nous,
chez nous, mais je parle chez nous. En
revanche, tout le monde accepte
d'énormes inégalités intellectuelles et
qu'il y en a qui fassent polytechnique
pendant que les autres sont laveur de
carreaux. Et ça ne perturbe personne.
Mon sentiment profond, c'est que dans le
futur, on évoluera comme dans la santé
et qu'on dira "Il n'est pas il n'est pas
acceptable qu'il y a de telles
inégalités intellectuelles. Il faut que
tout le monde puisse rentrer à centrale.
Il faut que tout le monde puisse aller à
Cambridge ou à dans des écoles
équivalentes. Et on dira ben l'école ne
sait pas faire ça et donc on va utiliser
les neurotechnologies ce qui posera
d'énormes problèmes de régulation. Mais
je pense qu'il vaut mieux dans le futur
qu'on égalise les capacités
intellectuelles par la technologie
plutôt que d'avoir des inégalité énorme
entre les losers de l'économie de demain
et puis les winners parce que les écarts
sont en train de devenir gigantesques,
notamment dans l'économie de
l'intelligence artificielle. Et j'ai
écrit plusieurs papiers sur euh le fait
que chez Google, on a maintenant dépassé
100 millions de dollars de bonus pour
des très très grands spécialistes de
l'intelligence artificielle. Euh c'est
euh les les informaticiens sont plus
payés chez Google que chez Syerview.
Philippe, est-ce que ça te fait est-ce
que ça te fait peur ça ? L'augmentation
génétique ? Non, ça ça me fait enfin ça
me fait peur. C'est c'est comme tout
franchissement de de de barrière
culturelle historique qu'a fait le le
fondement de de l'humanité.
Ça me ça me pose question mais j'ai du
mal à croire que ça arrive aussi aussi
facilement aussi automatiquement. Euh
j'ai dit à moyenne terme
oui voilà mais mais même que cette il y
ait cette marche de l'histoire forcément
systématique euh parce que euh
en fait on a on a cette ce développement
du numérique a été incroyable
effectivement dont le dépl le le le
l'accessibilité a été très grande.
C'estàdire qu'aujourd'hui il y a
évidemment encore des gens qui ont pas
accès à internet ou qu' on pas de quoi
se payer un smartphone et d'ailleurs qui
aimeraient bien même juste manger à leur
faim. Bon, mais effectivement, il y en a
peut-être de moins en moins et donc il y
a eu un un taux de pénétration
absolument
énorme et et très rapide de toutes ces
nouvelles technologies. Et du coup, on a
une tendance, je trouve, à se dire que
du coup, n'importe quelle nouvelle
technologie ou
euh ou ou progrès, enfin, je sais pas si
c'est un progrès mais pourrait être
déployé à cette même vitesse sous
prétexte que c'est un peu à base aussi
de numérique. Alors qu'en fait, il y a
il y a plein de domaines où aujourd'hui
euh euh il y a eu des il y a eu des
développements technologiques mais qui
n'ont pas permis l'accès à tout le monde
à ces à ces à ces chosesl.
même si le low a créé
a créé un nouvel espace il y a pas il y
a pas de loi de mour sur les avions.
Voilà exactement il y a pas loin de mour
dans l'économie physique. Alors là la
question que j'ai il y en a pas il y en
a pas en santé pour une raison très
simple
qu'on peut pas tuer des malades pour
voir.
Bah ça c'est fait en 39 45 non
non non non on peut pas tuer. Il faut
beaucoup de temps et on y va prudemment.
Quand on a un logiciel qui déconne, on
sort une version beta 1, elle merde, et
ben on
redistribue une betta 2 le lendemain,
puis une beta 3, puis une betta 4, puis
une beta 5. Et puis si ça fait planter
10h et qu'on a plus de musique pendant
une demi-heure, personne va pleurer.
Si on a une thérapie génique qui marche
pas bien, qui est pas bien évaluée et
qu'on tue 20 gamins à qui on et ben
c'est pas possible. Donc on est beaucoup
plus lent sur les technologies médicales
et génétiques qu'on l'est que dans les
dans les technologies numériques, ce
n'est pas scalable. Il y a une dimension
physique plus forte bien sûr et puis il
y a une inertie, on y va pas à pas, la
réglementation est nécessairement
beaucoup plus développée. Donc on ira
structurellement moins vite sur la
génétique que sur la musique online.
On arrive on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Il me reste quelques petites
questions. Euh dans la foulée et à la
volée. Euh pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
pris des parts dans la tribune ?
Je je suis actionnaire de la tribune
dans depuis longtemps.
26 %.
27 je crois.
27 % pourquoi ?
Euh pour soutenir la presse. Ça rapporte
rien. Euh ça ne fait que des pertes la
presse. Mais si on laisse crever les
journaux, c'est quand même emmerdant
pour la démocratie. Donc je fais partie
des gens qui soutiennent et c'est du
mécenat.
Euh je n'ai auc venir faire du Bén chez
nous.
Je n'ai aucun je n'ai aucun intérêt à le
faire mais je pense que il faut pas
laisser crever tous les journaux parce
que si on laisse que les blogueurs et
les Twitters fous
raconter des trucs des fake news les
urologues sénil
complotistes [grognement]
ça va être emmerdant. Je fais partie des
gens qui pensent que les médias Je pense
que je fais partie des gens qui pensent
que les médias avec leur filtres, avec
des journalistes professionnels apporte
quelque chose à sur le marché de
l'information et sur le marché de la
démocratie.
Le fait qu'ils aient plus que les
Français aient perdu confiance dans
leurs médias, c'est à propos de quoi ?
l'aire du temps, les inquiétudes, euh la
KJ, euh les fake news, le clientélisme,
plein plein de choses. Mais on voit
bien, on voit de plus en plus de
politiques aujourd'hui qui en ont
ralbol. Moi, je vois de faire de la
politique et donc euh on voit
derrière cette
méfiance vis-à-vis des médias et des
hommes politiques de la nation, on voit
des hommes politiques qui disent "J'en
ai marre, on n'est pas payé, on se fait
chier toute la journée, on est
corvéable." Mais non. à Mercend ça
dépend des échelles.
On fait du pantouflage, on vend le
carnet d'adresse.
Quand tu es président d'un conseil
général, tu gagnes 3500 par mois. Tu
bosses jour et nuit. Personne n'est
jamais content. Tu es soumis à une
pression d'enfer et on pense que tu t'en
fous plein les fouilles alors que ce
n'est pas vrai. Il n'y a pas de
corruption politique en France. Donc il
y a beaucoup d'hommes politiques. Non,
il y a pas de corruption il y a pas de
corruption politique généralisée en
France. Non, non et non. Euh non, c'est
pas vrai. Euh c'est une fake news. Les
hommes politiques sont euh dans
l'immense majorité des cas intègres. Et
donc on voit des gens qui arrêtent de
faire de la politique parce que euh euh
on se fait des couilles en or quand on
fait du business parce que dans la
nouvelle économie, il y a pas mal
d'argent à gagner et quand on fait de la
politique, on vous crache dessus et puis
tu gagnes pas beaucoup de sous. Donc il
faut qu'on fasse attention. Il faut pas
qu'on décourage les politiques, sinon on
aura une classe politique nulle. Et le
niveau de la classe politique baisse
aujourd'hui parce que si tu es pas payé,
personne est content, tu bosses jour et
nuit alors que à côté dans le business,
tu pourrais gagner beaucoup d'argent et
bien les hommes politiques vont partir
faire du business. D'ailleurs, on le
voit si on voit sur les hommes
politiques qui ont été battus depuis ces
dernières années, la plupart ils ont
arrêté la politique et maintenant ils
font du business où ils gagnent 10 20
100 fois plus qu' gagnaient en étant
ministre. On parle d'une certaine élite
parce que il y a aussi enfin 3500 € si
on compare ça au salaire médian ou au
salaire moyen français c'est pas si mal
que ça. Président d'un conseil gén le
président d'un conseil général c'est pas
le salaire médiant.
Ils sont pas tous oui non mais ils sont
ce que je veux dire c'est ils sont ils
sont pas tous foudroyants non plus et
ils ser ils feraiit pas tous des
étincelles dans le privé à devenir
forcément entrepreneur succès. Un
président un président de conseil
général c'est loin d'être un idiot.
Oui, sur un certain nombre de dimensions
certainement mais
et ça mérite et ça mérite plus de 3 3500
balles par mois
parce que dans le privé l'équivalent
gagne beaucoup beaucoup plus.
Est-ce que vous avez vu ?
C'est un avait mais Elon Mosque adore le
début d'hidocratie. C'est d'ailleurs en
regardant le début d'hiducratie qu'Elon
Mosque a créé Neuralink.
Parce que dans dans le début
d'idiocratie, les gens intelligents font
peu d'enfants et puis les abrutis font
plein d'enfants. Et ça a affolé Alon
Mosque. Elon Mosque a d'ailleurs déclaré
après avoir vu Hiocratie, je ne dis pas
qu'il faut empêcher les gens pas
intelligents de faire des enfants, mais
je voudrais que les femmes intelligentes
fassent autant d'enfants que les femmes
pas intelligentes, ce qui n'avait pas
été très bien vu dans certaines
universités
euh euh un peu gauchistes des
États-Unis. Et donc il s'est dit bah il
faut faire quelque chose, il faut
augmenter le cuit euh des gens. par des
technologies neur des neurotechnologies
et c'est là où il a eu l'idée de de
fabriquer des microprocesseurs pour
augmenter le QI des gens, les rendre
compétitifs face aux petits asiatiques
et puis face à à l'intelligence
artificielle. Mais pour l'instant, la
société qu'il a créé il y a déjà 4 ans
maintenant, Neuralink n'a encore délivré
aucun dispositif qui augmente les
capacités intellectuelles. Je pense
qu'il a été présomptueux comme
d'habitude sur le délai.
Je ne pense pas une seconde que
Neuraling va sortir son premier
prototype en 2022-2023 comme il l'avait
annoncé quand il a créé la boîte.
Euh donc je réponds à la communauté.
Oui, il a déjà accepté un débat avec
Éric Sadin mais Éric Sadin est sur
d'autres sujets en ce moment. Est-ce que
Non, tu c'est pas vrai. Éric Sadin
refuse de débattre. C'est tout à fait
différent. Il est pas sur d'autres
sujets. Il ose pas débattre.
Nous arrivons donc à la partie la plus
croustillante. Est-ce que vous avez des
livres à conseiller ? Trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté. On va
commencer par Philippe Bwix.
Voilà, c'est dur, je m'étais pas du tout
préparé. Euh
alors je dirais Matthew Crawford,
l'éloge du carburateur parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui montre en fait que le le
clivage aujourd'hui dans le travail
n'est plus entre l'école blanc et
l'école bleue mais entre là où il faut
mettre de l'intelligence dans son
travail et là où il faut pas en mettre
et qu'il y a toute une série de métiers
manuels. par exemple le bâtiment sans
parler d'un certain parties d'artisanat
et cetera où il y a beaucoup
d'intelligence à mettre et au contraire
il y a des métiers peut-être dit plus
intellectuel où il y a pas forcément
tant que ça de questions à se poser et
du coup qui voilà qui remet un peu au au
goût du jour cette question de la valeur
de du du travail manuel qu'on a
tellement tellement dévalorisé en en
France enfin et dans les pays occident
en toute manière générale et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui bah on narrive pas à
trouver forcément des des gens qui
s'intègrent. Alors, je sais pas si tout
le monde fera central en 2050, mais à ce
momentl faudra faire central et être
capable d'être bien que tout le monde en
2050 puisse faire s'il le souhaite
central.
Voilà. Mais après, il faudra quand même
aller des gens pour aller réparer le
carrelage. Donc effectivement, faudra ça
ça pose une question si on a pas
revalorisé les c de métier
refaire le carnage.
Le premier, le deè bon
le deuxè
Les Mumford technique et civilisation
qui vient d'être réédité. Lewis Merford,
c'est un grand penseur du 20e siècle,
penseur de la de la technique et qui est
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant et
sympathique.
Et puis euh le 3è
euh Olivier Ray, une question de taille,
je crois que j'avais déjà cité SC
philosophe. Bah, il a d'ailleurs gagné
un ou de prix. Non non, c'est c'est très
enfin pour moi intellectuellement très
important de se dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on se pose des questions, il faut
réfléchir à l'échelle à laquelle on se
pose ces question. On peut pas parler de
la la concurrence et du libéralisme sans
se poser la question de l'échelle.
C'est-à-dire que le le concurrent
boulanger, c'est génial, mais est-ce que
le concourc nucléaire est-ce que c'est
bien ou pas bien ? Voà, c'est des
questions comme ça. La question
politique tout à l'heure, c'est la
question de l'échelle aussi. C'est je
pense qu'on a pas du tout le même
personnel politique et les mêmes actions
et les mêmes engagements à différents
niveaux. Voilà. et il remet tout ça au
goût du jour aussi qui un peu la pensée
de d'Ivanin d'une part et de de
Schumarer d'autre part et un FR
Schumarer Small is beautiful. Donc voilà
et et donc on a on a pris le troisème
Laurent Alexandre qui pianote euh une
question d'
maintenant je prends les derniers les
derniers que j'ai j'ai lu.
Ouais
enfin parmi les derniers que j'ai lu.
Alors avant avant votre théoricité dans
vos votre livre sur l'intelligence et
l'hérédité viennent-elle de James Watson
?
Vous répondrez à la à la personne qui a
posé cette question que c'est un pervers
narcissique. Alors [raclement de gorge]
alors des bouquins des bouquins que je
trouve très intéressants. Il y a le
bouquin de Bryan Caplan
The Case Against Education qui est un
bouquin passionnant où il montre que
finalement l'enseignement supérieur
n'augmente pas les capacités des gens
mais simplement une machine à les
sélectionner.
Oui.
Et c'est très très très très
convaincant.
C'est du dieu. C'est un remis en goû du
jour. Ah non non, c'est pas du bourdieu
parce que si c'était bourdieu, j'en
parlerai pas. Je déteste bourdieux. Donc
ça c'est un très bon bouquin.
Pourquoi détest bour ?
J'ai le droit de détester les
gauchistes. Euh
il y a vraiment un bouquin que j'aime
beaucoup qui est le bouquin de Kaifly
AI Powers qui est une analyse économique
de l'intelligence artificielle avec une
couverture toute rouge qui est vraiment
vraiment
extrême
extrêmement intéressant. Et puis
on a parlé d'école et cetera.
Il y a deux bouquins remarquables. Alors
donc je vais en citer quatre. Il y a le
bouquin de plomine Blueprint qui est
vraiment remarquable et puis il y a
Neuroscience of intelligence ailleurs
qui est la meilleure synthèse de la
façon dont notre intelligence est
produite, dont notre cerveau est créé
par nos gènes, par l'environnement,
notre alimentation et c'est un bouquin
absolument remarquable. Donc ailleurs
plumine euh le Capelan,
c'est c'est pas mal.
Donc avant de se dire au revoir, la
fameuse question qui n'est pas une
question, c'est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui va rester sur les
réseaux. Philippe Wix,
oh moi c'est la 4e fois que je passe al
4e conseil, je sais plus ce que j'ai
raconté.
Faisons preuve de technodiscernement
systématiquement dans toutes nos
réflexions qu'elles soient personnell ou
sociétal.
Jouissez,
profitez
et n'écoutez pas les prophètes de
malheur apocalyptique qui vous
démoralisent.
La vie est belle contrairement à ce
qu'on vous raconte.
Le bonheur était pour demain, titre de
mon ouvrage
[rires]
messieurs. Merci.
Merci.
[musique]